this is jocko podcast number 329 with
echo charles and me jocko willink good
evening echo good evening
at 1800 the bull
and lieutenant colonel sidner walked on
the
stage the room got dead silent when the
bull began to talk
bull was a man of few words
the briefing theater was a short walk
from our barracks
inside it had simple rows of wood
seating like two by ten boards on short
metal poles no seat backs
it would seat around a hundred
there was an elevated stage with a
screen
we had watched a movie there just a
couple days prior
bull reveals a large map
and says
quote
we are going to rescue 70 american
prisoners of war maybe more
from a camp called sante
the target is 23 miles west of hanoi
this is something our american prisoners
of war have a right to expect from their
fellow
soldiers we are all part of the same
military family we want these men to
know that they are not abandoned by
their military family no man should feel
that way
that's why we are going in
there after them
you are to let nothing nothing interfere
with the operation
our mission is to rescue prisoners not
to take prisoners
if there's been a leak
we'll know it by the time the second or
third chopper sets down
if we're walking into a trap if it turns
out that they know we're coming
don't even dream about walking out of
north vietnam
unless you've got wings on your feet
we'll be a hundred miles from laos
it's the wrong part of the world for a
retrograde maneuver
if it happens i want to keep this force
together
we'll back up to the song kong river
if we have to and by god they're welcome
to come across that damn open ground
we'll make them pay for every foot
across that son of a [__]
for about four seconds you could have
heard a pin drop
then
like a cannon shot everyone bursts out
shouting whooping hollering slapping
each other on the back raring like
broncos yelling let's go get em
bull tries to bring us back to earth by
explaining in no uncertain terms that he
estimates each man has a 50 50 chance of
returning alive from this mission
he states that this is strictly a
volunteer mission
if any man has a reason that he should
not go on this mission he should decide
now
not a single man backed out
the whole meeting including lieutenant
colonel sidner's portion lasted no
longer than 10 minutes
and that right there
is an excerpt
from a book called
who will go
into the sante pow camp written by terry
buckler
and is about one of the most famous
special operations
missions of all time the attempted pow
rescue on the sante prison camp in
vietnam
and the author terry buckler
a special forces soldier green beret
was on that raid
he was actually the youngest man on that
mission
and we have the honor of having him here
with us tonight to share some of his
lessons learned
from this incredible mission and from
his life terry
thank you for joining us
my pleasure
it's an honor to have you here this is
something that i've heard about for many
many years anyone that's in the special
operations community knows about
this raid
and the impact that it had
not just on the pows
but also in in the history and the
continued evolution of special
operations as a whole
so it's uh
pretty pretty humbling to be sitting
here talking to you
that that you were actually on that raid
um how did you end up coming on this
podcast was your daughter my daughter
she's acting like my agent
she had told me about you and i started
looking up
uh some of your podcasts that you had
done and
i thought wow and then started looking
at your following my goodness
you're better than trump
so
i don't know about all that
but uh she's the one who
got the ball rolling for it well i'm i'm
definitely glad she she reached out and
this is just an incredible story the had
an awesome time reading this book
and we'll go over some of this book
today i'll start off by saying obviously
i can't read the whole book
um get the book yourself if you want to
hear the entire story but i want to hit
some wave tops of it because it's just
an incredible story and um
well usually like to start off in the
beginning kind of where you came from
and
to introduce those topics i'll i'll go
to the book
okay so it says here i was born in a
two-bedroom house on a small 72-acre
farm in central missouri in
we were six miles from clark
six from rennick and six from higbee
our mail came through clark i went to
school at renick and our phone came
through higbee
clark happens to be the birthplace of
famous world war ii general omar bradley
our house had been built in 1870
we didn't have indoor plumbing until
when i was 12.
so that's uh
that's a little different than people
grow up now huh just a little bit
um
well what tell me a little bit more
about you know growing up in that in
those conditions
well you know we were by ourselves our
neighbors were in the same boat that we
were pretty much we had one neighbor
down the road that actually had indoor
plumbing
and it was always kind of nice
they had three kids and one of them was
the same age as me we grew up together
and you know sometimes we'd spend nights
at each other's house and it was always
nice to go to his house because you get
a [__] get a bath and hot water
so what'd you guys did you boil water to
go and take a bath at your house
sometimes sometimes we boil water other
times we set a tub out in the sun in the
summer
and then we'd bring it in the house and
one of the stories when i was a growing
up and my parents had gone to town and i
was taking a bath
and
we had a stove and the stoves we had
back in those days didn't have the metal
surrounding it was just there was the
heat and there was a fire and i lost my
balance and
my butt fell back into the
net
against the
stove and
needless to say i had a nice little burn
out of it
couldn't go to school for about a week
because i couldn't wear any clothes and
it was embarrassing to me to go to
school when people started saying why
why were you out
and i said oh it's just one of those
things you know hurt my butt
so that's what you call burn-ins i guess
yeah uh you say in here dad was a
hard-working man but he also enjoyed
having fun when he returned from the war
in 1946 he worked as a coal miner
alongside his dad in rock springs
wyoming
after he was injured injured in a mine
cave-in
he decided he was not interested in a
miner's career and moved back to
missouri where he had been raised
in 1947 he purchased the 72 acres i came
to know as our farm
he attended classes on agriculture at
the technical college under the gi bill
and you say this uh let me pause to tell
you about my father's service in the
army world war ii was when he served he
never talked about the war until one
saturday in july 1997 after he had had
his stroke and was recovering in the
university of missouri hospital
that and i started talking about what he
did in the army from basic training
until he was released from active duty
dad spent 36 months in the south pacific
we talked about what it was like to get
shot at and how it felt to shoot another
person
dad was a very laid-back person it was
hard to imagine him shooting someone we
compared the food the army fed us and
the types of weapons we had we both
carried a cult 45
our long rifles were very different we
talked about fear while in combat
now
you say your dad didn't really talk
about that until 1997. right so did you
did you hear did you know he was in
world war ii growing up yeah i knew he
had been in world war ii but we never
talked about it and
when i i volunteered for the draft and
uh
when i came home and told my parents
what i'd done you know my mom of course
she broke into tears and
dad kind of understood the situation and
i remember
he took me to the bus station to go to
kansas city for the induction or take my
physical
and that's that was really the first
time we talked a little about
what it was like and
in war and he he told me don't volunteer
for anything
so i really listened to me famous last
words yes
uh
you say when i turned 15 i spent most of
my summers working for a neighbor who'd
farmed about 500 acres my brothers had
worked for him until they graduated then
i took their place you were class
president
you had a you you had a really small
school growing up 19 in your graduating
class yes you were class president yes
you played the only sport you had was
basketball correct which you were not
genetically engineered to play
i wasn't the tallest guy on the team by
any stretch of the imagination
but you played did you play varsity uh
well we didn't have anything but varsity
so you were just playing you had one
team you played on it or you didn't play
so and when you only got 19 in your
class you can't be real picky
uh
you say after graduating from high
school i moved to columbia to work this
summer for my uncle rodney who owned a
tree service since 1950.
in the fall of 1968 i moved to
louisville kentucky to attend trade
school for electronics i had a job
working construction in the mornings and
went to school in the afternoon i did
this until january of 1969 when i ran
out of money
it was the end of february 1969 when a
couple of my high school buddies and i
were riding around the big town of
moberly and decided to stop that the
draft stopping at the draft board to see
where we were on the draft list we'd all
been in technical school and back then
when you lost your draft to furman from
college it seemed like you jumped up on
the draft list
the lady at the draft board told me that
it would probably be april before i'd be
drafted i asked her when the next group
was scheduled to go and she told us it
would be march i asked her to add me to
the list so that was it i just
volunteered for the us army
correct
so this is
1969 i mean the vietnamese war is
clearly going on
and you're seeing this in the news every
day you know i've had quite a few people
on the podcast that when they were
joining the military
it was 1965 66 they the vietnam wasn't a
guarantee like it must have been for you
you must have known 100 you were going
to vietnam
that was exactly right i mean
in those days
they needed troops and uh
you know it cost me another year of my i
volunteered for a two-year but to get
into special forces i had to
extend another year for training
so
mine became a three-year commitment
were there
like hippies where you were in moberly
or was was there not not so much in
moberly but at fort bragg
where i ended up uh
after basic and ait and jump school
yeah we had our
drain fondas and our uh
those uh
people that like to protest but it was
it seemed like for you and your group of
friends
just patriotic this is what's going on
yep
exactly
there's a rural area i mean you know
hippies were kind of thought of as
weirdos
still are in my mind but you know
that's just the way it goes
uh
summer love i guess was a little bit
different for you and mobley yeah just a
little bit
you say on march 17 1969 the day to
report to the mobile draft office my mom
got me up early and dad
and fixed dad and me a big breakfast
before she went to work there in the
kitchen my mom gave me a big hug and we
kissed she told me she loved me she told
me to be safe that was a tough day for
mom as she walked out of the kitchen
door to go to work i could see she was
crying
dad had taken the morning off to drive
me to moberly so i could catch the
missouri transit bus to kansas city for
my physical and my swearing in it was
bright sunny morning driving to moberly
dad had a nice talk to me about what to
expect army basic training
he advised me to take it all with a
grain of salt
dad had served in the pacific theater
during world war ii and had seen his
share of combat in the philippines
standing at the bus stop we hugged and
he gave me some more good advice keep
your nose clean your head down
and don't volunteer for anything
dad wiped back his tears as he walked
back to his car
it's got a little bit of a different
meaning when
the war's going on in vietnam
and your dad had actually fought himself
in southeast asia he knows exactly what
you're getting into exactly
and he gave you some good advice which
we're gonna find out you did not listen
to
you're right
uh
boot camp here we were issued our
new nice green uniforms and all the good
stuff that comes with it underwear socks
boots and blankets our new friends the
drill sergeants marched us or at least
we called it marching over to get our
first army haircut it took about one
minute but it was free and you know what
they say you get what you pay for
i'd only been in the army a few days
when our company was brought into one of
our training buildings there was this
big bad looking rambo guy who was
looking for volunteers for the green
berets
i didn't know a lot about the green
berets but i did know they were one of
the most elite fighting units in the
army this guy looked as though he could
have kicked any ten of us at once
i thought if i'm going to war i want to
go with the best so i raised my hand
when he asked if anyone wanted to
volunteer for the green berets special
forces i knew this would cost me another
year of service but i figured another
year is worth the price to pay to be
among the army's best
i guess i was a poor listener when it
came to my dad's advice about
volunteering so how much did you know
about special forces
not a whole lot other than the green
beret you know
uh the song barry sadler yeah had that
out and uh
you know
i knew
that
special forces was special and
but i really i knew no one at that time
that was in special forces but i i had
done a little reading on
them when i was
thinking about joining the military
before i actually volunteered
but
i always felt like if i was going to go
i wouldn't go with the best how many
guys from your boot camp company do you
think volunteered
me
yeah
it was kind of uh you know
i thought well you know that's why it's
special maybe
what percentage of your boot camp
company was draftees would you say oh
probably
wow yeah we had most of us are all
draftees we had a few
guys that were
in a reserve or national guard but the
rest of us are just draftees
and
you know we were there because uncle sam
needed us there
and so we took on the role of a soldier
um
what was the what was the
kind of shock value of boot camp for you
having grown up on a farm you've been
working hard your whole life i mean
were you you you're getting it might
have been easy for you i had one of my
guys worked on a dairy farm up in
minnesota and for him being in the
military was easy it was a vacation
i agree
you know
it wasn't
i remember that
you know
we had a
when my dei who was a veteran of vietnam
found out that i was going to jump
school
and there was another palmer 17 year old
palmer and that guy got me in more
trouble he was going to jump school
and so anytime
he messed up i had to pay for it so i
started messing up so he had to pay for
it and we had a run in battle and drill
sergeant dunham was our drill sergeant
and
uh he just
i remember we doing the pugle sticks
and he
called our number and we'd go out
and
then he'd call somebody else's number
and they'd come in but he wouldn't leave
us he left us out there you know and
then when i got tired he'd call for
palmer's number
and it got to a point where the guys
felt sorry for us and of course dunham
said you guys either start smacking him
or we will start smacking you and so you
know
they didn't have a real good choice and
those little helmets we wore weren't
worth that
peace pot for nothing but
i remember coming out and thinking man
my head was ringing crazy but you know
that was the way it was and
why was palmer going to airborne school
he just wanted to go to the 82nd oh
awesome yeah he didn't want to go to
special forces and he went to go to the
82nd airborne
and
but he was he was a stocky young kid and
17 years old smart knew everything he
thought
and
i think we're all blessed with that at
age 17.
i kept thinking keep your mouth shut
how long was boot camp do you remember
eight weeks yeah
and did you get any infantry or is it
just very basic kind of indoctrination
military pretty pretty basic you know
and then my ait i was a combat engineer
on
my ait which is at fort eleven or
leonard wood as well
so i spent basic in leonard wood and i
spent my ait at leonard wood
so that's just
advanced training extended period of
time you're there now
how did you end up getting an mos of
combat engineer did that get assigned to
you yeah that was that was in case you
didn't make it through special forces
training exactly yeah you went through
your basic whatever the army you know
whatever your military occupation is
going to be
and then once you got into special
forces then you decided you had a choice
of you know medic
you know we had the best medics and then
weapons
communications and
and intelligence and all that was
and you were cross-trained on all that
yeah same thing they have now seen the
same system now right
um
you took your first airplane ride
after ait you say experienced my first
airplane ride it took me from fort
leonard leonard wood to fort benning
georgia
jump school as much as i expected a lot
of running and push-ups and when you
screwed up in morning inspections
i went through jump school in august
fast forward a little bit here you said
i had the good fortune of going through
jump school with some navy seals from
team two if i recall correctly
when they learned that i was headed for
special forces training they decided
they would adopt me into their ranks
the water troughs we
we had were about a foot deep and 18
inches wide the seals stopped up one of
the troughs and filled it with water
then about six of them grabbed me and
dunked me in the water until i thought i
was going to drown from then on they
deemed me an honorary seal
i guess you might say i had my first
taste of water boarding
they were actually a great bunch of guys
one day we were headed back to the
barracks after a day of training one of
the seals was made to run around the
platoon while we did the airborne
shuffle
well the seals have a very high degree
of esprit de corps if one of them was
dropped for push-ups they all did
push-ups so if one seal had to run
around our platoon they all would think
about that the seals were running
circles around us as we soldiers did the
airborne shuffle now to say this pissed
off the cadre as an understatement the
next thing i knew we were running what
felt like a sprint as the seals ran
around the platoons by the time we made
it back to the barracks we were all
exhausted the cadre then had the seals
doing push-ups for the next 10 or 15
minutes i'd developed a real
appreciation for the level of
camaraderie the seals have
i
went to airborne school they don't seals
don't go to airborne school anymore in
fort benning georgia they they go
through the navy has their own little
program now oh really but so i i was i
don't know when they stopped it it was
quite a few years after me but it was
definitely that situation when we go
down there you know we were
like you said earlier we were so we were
young so we thought we knew everything
right but we were definitely in good
shape because we were just coming out of
seal training and
airborne
school especially this is like 1990
1991 i think
is when i was going through airborne
school so at that time there's all kinds
of people from the army going through
airbornes right and the air force it
wasn't
it wasn't though it wasn't high
standards of physical training
not very high so you know we come out of
basic seal training where we're like
animals right
and we're just having fun they can't do
anything to hurt us
had some good really good memories of
the black hats down there they were
awesome they were they were very cool
uh yeah it's it's too bad they don't
join us up for that anymore it's kind of
fun even though i'll tell you i had a
kid asking me about it the other day and
man that that's weird that's where i
really learned about the hurry up and
wait like never before i mean you get
you know we'd meet at two o'clock in the
morning to start getting your parachute
on
at
four o'clock in the morning you're
getting your first inspection at six
o'clock in the morning you're taking a
bus out to the plane at eight o'clock in
the morning you're getting on the plane
at ten o'clock in the morning the plane
takes off and at noon you jump
i've been doing this for 10 hours this
is a 30-second evolution
and that hasn't changed
good times
uh
you finish
airborne school
and you roll into september 1969 special
forces training you say
one certain night in september 1969 74
top-notch soldiers out of a hundred
screw out of hundreds
jumped into the dz at camp mccall near
fort bragg with all our equipment and
one change of fatigues that's all we
would have for the next few weeks we
were about four miles from what would be
our what would become our base camp it
was about 10 p.m and the welcome
committee was ready for us now you could
tell these guys really look forward to
our arrival the cadre quickly assembled
and started marching us to camp up on
this dirt road with our rucksacks and
our weapons so this is your start of
special forces training you're going
you're jumping into school all right
correct my call and you just have what
you have on you an extra change of camis
and
your gear regular gear yep dude what
kind of brief did you get before this
did you get a brief break i don't recall
any briefing you know you said we're
going to camp mccall and we all knew
that's the either that's where the
washout started you know
and so so
once you start
once you start this this section of
special forces training and people start
washing out are they quitting are they
failing what's going on uh combination
some guys you know on the just on the
night in that first night we lost
probably 15 guys
just uh it wasn't for them i mean they
couldn't take the
the harassment and the guys yeah i mean
those the cadre out there were
you know they uh
they knew how to get under your skin
and in a very short time
i remember seeing some guys get so bad
you know they took a swing at them and
it was like oh you don't want to do that
you know
wrong wrong wrong and
next thing you know you know that person
isn't around anymore you know
and uh but that's
that's the way one way of weeding them
out you know and getting people there
that really
wanted to be in special forces and knew
that there was going to be some
ups and downs to the training part of it
and
and then all through
i think we were out there like eight
weeks
and
you know you learned you know all the
basics of you know patrolling things
like that they went into a little more
advanced you know how to set up ambushes
and then you know different
uh
types of
medical deals and
going on a raid you know
or a mission
and you had to write your mission
reports and things like that see
it was a kind of an overall view of
everything that you would need in an a
team
and you know at this point we weren't
medics we weren't weapons we were just
green green berets and that
you know we're just hoping to get to the
next level to where they could then
select the mos we wanted and go that's
when the training really started for
special forces this was we're going to
weed you out we're going to make sure
that this is what you want because if
you don't it can't handle this you're
not going to handle anything else and we
don't want you
i forgot to mention that when you were
in boot camp you scored a perfect 500 on
the on the physical fitness test so you
were just a good athlete for sure i was
i was in good shape back then and a fast
runner you mentioned that specifically
you were a fast runner um
and then
you you know it are you doing a lot of
patrolling like long long marches during
special forces training because i think
it's different now yeah i was gonna say
it
they they weren't long marches but you
know you you'd go out and
camp out overnight you know and kind of
make do with what you had you know
everybody had their
little tents but you know a lot of times
we didn't even use them we just unroll a
sleeping bag and sleep out under the
stars so to speak
and
that was part of it as well
how much were you eating
uh well you had back then we had you
know see rations you know so
they would bring in
uh
the meals and i mean we made those were
our meals for all three meals you know
we had
pound cake
ham and mothers
was a favorite and then
beans and weenies you know of course
they'd put it bring it out in a big you
know 50 gallon or a 25 gallon
[Music]
full of water and they put the heaters
in them
so they'd heat your food
and then you had your p-38 and open the
can and
that's
and you can hear guys trying to barter
with you know some ham and [__]
were the first you know nobody wanted
them i need you or some kind i'll trade
this for a pound cake
the pound cakes were rotten too you know
but uh you know that that was before sea
ration or uh uh lerps came out for us so
yeah it's always uh
by you know i went through basic seal
training and there you get to eat and
you get to eat actually a lot most of
the time you're getting three meals a
day and usually one or two of them are
in a chow hall where it's basically all
you can eat
and i always feel
you know the rangers that get one mre a
day for whatever that is you know 85
days
and
you know they those guys always lose 20
15 20 25 pounds i gained
i gained 11 pounds
through seal yeah i went from 174 to 185
and that's working out however long
you're working out you know doing a ton
of physical activity but i was just
eating a ton and you could get like get
done at night
i would be ordering pizza at at 10
o'clock or 11 o'clock at night i'd order
pizza dominoes would would deliver
we would eat pizza just about well we
eat up pizza on a lot of nights so we're
getting a lot of calories
but i always found that the
the army
has a little bit more stringent about
what they're going to let you eat in
their special forces schools
i i remember the first time i ate at an
air force
oh yeah my god next level oh yeah
i mean i remember they say i ask you how
you want your eggs
and i'm thinking you're asking
you know normally it's scrambled you
know and i told them how i like my eggs
and they said okay and i thought i'm
gonna like this place
yeah the air force definitely puts a
priority on oh yeah on comfort i will
say on comfort they do i've always heard
that the air force like when they design
a base
the first thing they build is the
barracks then they build the recreation
then they build the gymnasium then they
build the pool then they build the golf
course and now they're just about any
out of money and they say to the
government well we still need an air you
know we still need an airstrip
you know and some hangers and they go
well we don't have any choice but to
build it so
that's what i've always heard i don't
know if that's true but it's a smart
idea really yeah
was there anything that was really hard
for you going through the initial
special forces selection no i uh you
know i kind of breezed through it i
remember the first time i was ever
exhausted where i couldn't do push-ups
was the night we landed and
we kept up my another guy lol and i kept
up with the cadre
all the way into
the base camp and then when we got there
you know of course they asked the
question are you tired and we knew it
was a trick question and we said no and
he said drop do push-ups and i literally
i could not do another push-up you know
i mean i thought oh no this is it
they're going to flush me
but you know when the other guys all got
in you know they said get up and get
back and fall in and so i thought oh we
got a blessing there so
uh
you say this in the book um
i always try to add humor to anything
that i do
one early morning the company was in
formation waiting for the cadre to join
us on that day i was the student company
commander while we were waiting i
shouted out a command that anyone who
that can't tamped out tamp tap dance
must be a [__]
well the entire company started tap
dancing in place
all of a sudden they all stopped i had
my back to the cadre building and it was
at that time that i realized i was the
only one still tap dancing i stopped and
slowly turned around and stood there and
there stood the cadre
they did have a sense of humor and got a
chuckle out of it but they told me to
drop and start doing push-ups
and here you have one of your first life
lessons in this book
life lesson one add humor
it really helps when things are getting
tough sometimes it's not easy to find it
within you but even the pows somehow
found a way to pass some slivers of
humor through the cracks in the prison
walls the soul needs it
make sure you contribute some for the
benefit of the people around you
yep you know i mean it's interesting
that we're sitting here laughing about
these stories anyways because you got to
have fun doing this stuff even when it's
miserable exactly
um you get done with selection and you
say i was sent to my
special forces mos in special forces
there were five mos options weapons
engineer communication intel and medical
um and you ended up with uh
communications mos now is that because
you
is that right
oh i thought you did
i i did communications on the raid okay
but my mos was uh 12 bravo i was an
engineer okay weapon are
demolitions so they kept you and you
were an engineer anyways you'd been
through
ait or right that was as an engineer so
they put you as an engineer okay
they did some things right
and would you learn about so so talk a
little bit about engineers what are you
doing in that specialty uh we learned
how to build bridges you know across
rivers and things like that and then of
course part of that was demolitions you
know how to use det core and how to
build your own bombs for you know soap
dishes and dust initiators things like
that
that were used and then
you know how to how to basically use a
dead cord to knock down trees and stuff
and
it was uh i remember the class after me
we lost about eight or nine guys in an
accident out on a
demo range
you know what happened we had a uh
the
guy that was doing connecting
we did what's called a ring main
and
in the ring main the last one that
connects
is then connected to the hot wire on the
battery and we were using the electric
blasting caps
and they forgot to disconnect the other
side
and we lost about eight or nine guys
on one
at the end of the day and they were all
kneeling over there
uh working on it yeah it was a it was a
real shame
but
you know somebody forgot
and
awesome good men
man yep
go that's awful
yeah those uh
you got to pay attention when you're
working with demolition
you just have to yeah
one one little air like that can
you put an end to your career that's for
sure
and i bet the guy that was actually near
the blasting machine
he wasn't by a charge right so he lived
yeah he lived
and had to live with that the rest of
his life
man so yeah
um
fast forward a little bit um
you say here after i completed special
forces mos training in march 1970
we were all then assigned to a group at
this time fifth group was responsible
for vietnam and as warriors everyone
wanted to be assigned to fifth group
including myself
however there were two groups at fort
bragg sixth group and seventh group i
was assigned a seventh group like any
good soldier you do as you are told and
make the best of it i was proud to be a
green beret
that summer brought me to the nut and
holla am i saying that right no really
not in haley uh national forest from
which i was picked to be part of bull
simon's mysterious
mission
so on september 2nd 1970
as a member of the advance party we
loaded on the c123s
southbound so
bill simons
this guy is a legend
um world war ii
he fought in new guinea he was a ranger
he conducted a raid
uh that was a that was a pow rescue they
rescued in the philippines
over 500 pows
many of whom had participated in the
baton death march
uh then he'd gotten out for a couple
years
and then came back in he was in special
forces
he was in sog
i mean he this guy was a a legendary guy
and how did that happen that you got
picked for this for this mission how did
you hear about the mission how did you
get picked well uh i was up at nata
haley and i was training
i was working with a bunch of master
sergeants and
being e5 and
we were teaching mountain climbing and
rope tie into officers and some of the
guys in seventh group
and
we needed some supplies so
colonels
told me to go into town and pick up
supplies
and which neda haley's about no probably
250 300 miles from fort bragg
so i went back down to bragg
and a couple of my buddies said when i
got down and they said hey do you see
where bill simons is looking for
volunteers and of course bill simons i
mean just
i mean
that wasn't enough to
excite you then you didn't want to be
there so
uh i said well i'm going to go down and
see what he's
talking about because they said if you
wanted he was going to be down at the
what we call the little white house
there fort bragg
got down there it was packed i mean
there was probably 500 plus
special forces guys there
and bull came out on the stage and
he always had a little cigar in his
mouth he never smoked it i don't know he
just chewed on it you know but he
yeah i and i had never seen the guy so
that was kind of my first uh
introduction to colonel sinha
he looks like
a legend
his physical appearance he looks like a
legend he is a legend and
i i mean he's yeah yeah there's no doubt
about that
and
so when he came on stage you know he
said i was looking for
uh some volunteers for a moderately
hazardous mission
and uh i always wondered what he called
hazardous
[Laughter]
compared to what we were
getting ready to go do but uh
uh he said there's no tdy so you know
that eliminated some guys uh you know
everybody wants temporary money duty
money
and uh he said if you're interested get
back here and we'll start the interview
process at 300 hours
so
i uh i went back
and
put my name on the list and the next
i came back
to they had two sergeant majors doing a
lot of the interviewing two command
sergeant majors
and
we were in line at the seventh group uh
facility
billets
and
it was about no probably about 5 30 i
guess and i'm standing there and
nobody's called me nobody's called me
everybody else pretty much gone and out
walks these two sergeant majors
and they're walking out the door and i'm
thinking
they didn't interview me
and so i ran after him and hollered at
him i said you know hey you guys didn't
interview me
and they said what's your name and i
said buckler and they said
well and he had a clipboard on he looked
and he says
i don't have your 201 file that's the
military and army that's your
file tells you everything about who you
are and what you've done and your
records
and i said they said uh well i want to
interview and they said well you get
your 201 file i'll be back here first
thing in the morning we'll interview you
so okay so
uh buddy man at that time was one of my
roommates a bunch of us lived off base
you know we had seven of us
in
in the sixth and seven of us and
uh seventh group so we were the only
time we were together was payday and
holidays
and so
we kind of
the neighborhood i think was glad to see
us move but
you know
the deputy sheriff lived down the road
from us and he was always stopping by
and said guys can you just hold it down
just a little bit
yeah
so but anyway um
i went in for the interview you know and
they asked me if i could weld and i said
i grew up on a farm and our neighbor sam
welded everything we ever broke so i
looked at that i thought
i can do that so i said yeah i'm a
welder and you so you felt like you
could weld because you watched your
buddy
okay i like it i like your attitude
that's good attitude yeah i didn't they
didn't have a welder so i wouldn't have
to prove myself yet and then they want
to know if i did scuba and i i hadn't at
that point done scuba so i said no i
don't know scuba and then they just
asked me some general questions you know
what how much combat have you been
and i'm thinking they got my two on one
file i have no combat experience
and so i said no i've no
none so i said okay well thanks i
thought well at least they let me
interview so you know thank you and i
walked out the door
got back up tonight haley then and a
couple days later a colonel from our
called me into his office up at the net
hayley there and he says
pack your bag
and i said well okay
he says you made bill simon's list
and i said really and he said yep so i
said okay and
then i went you know i'm very excited
not even knowing what we were going to
do just the fact that we made it did you
have any idea why they selected you to
this day i the only thing i could figure
out is they needed some
in special forces aside from your
crack welding skills
i never thought about that one yeah
i think what they needed was some grunts
and special forces and e5 is the lowest
rank
so they
i i was on the advanced party and we
went down and set up the compound and
we
when they swept the building we put the
constantino wire around and put the
field phone out and then i pulled guard
duty on the we had to guard that
building 24 by seven
and i thought it was a little unusual
because and when we pulled guard duty at
bragg yeah you got an
m16 in one round maybe you know
and this one we had an m16 in full round
and we ordered if something goes south
shoot
and that i thought
there's something serious on this
mission that
they're not telling everybody about but
you know we did what we were told to do
and
that's i pulled guard duty and when i
wasn't pulling guard duty i was either
sleeping
or training because i had to train with
the other guys during
when i wasn't pulling guard duty
you say this uh so you fly down there
and where's the location you fly to in
eglin air force eglin air force base so
you say now bull wasn't the only
legendary officer attached to the sante
raid
captain dick meadows would lead blue boy
assault group which would land directly
inside the pow camp walls enlisted in
1946 a paratrooper in the korean war in
the early 60s
meadows served a stint with the british
special air service in vietnam meadows
captured video footage proving north
vietnam
army was infiltrating south vietnam and
impressed general westmoreland so much
that in 1967 he received a battlefield
commission directly to captain
he was the commanding officer of ranger
school when bull simons recruited him
for the sante raid
lieutenant colonel
bud sidner
was selected by bull simons to serve as
the ground forces commander whereas bull
simon's role would be the on-scene eyes
and ears of the joint contingency task
group in constant contact with general
manor
lieutenant colonel sidner had the
reputation of a gentleman and a
consummate professional
one day
brigadier general blackburn from the
pentagon brigadier general manor
bull simons and captain dick meadows
showed up as a group and requested
access to the operations center i
checked their ids and called in for
someone to come out and escort them in
lieutenant colonel sidner comes out the
gate can you imagine how i felt here i
am a 20 year old buck sergeant standing
in the midst of some of the most notable
special operations forces officers ever
i remember
they treated me as one of them making
small talk with me after a while
lieutenant carl sidner took them inside
this is one of the great things about
special forces the officers and enlisted
men treat each other with respect i
believe this is because you have to
depend on one another when you operate
in small teams like special forces so
they were super strict about who's
coming into this building
yeah i mean it was you didn't get into
the building i don't care how many times
you've been in that building
when you wanted back in i had to check
your id and or whoever the guard was
called in and we had a field phone set
up they'd call in somebody would come
out
and verify that they were who they were
and let them in and escort them into the
building
and were you go to getting to go into
the building no no so you don't even
know what you're guarding
we used to laugh about that because we'd
say what what they got in there you know
that they're so privacy about you know
we kept thinking women
but we knew that could happen because
none of us escorted them in
so but uh yeah they were very strict i
mean on that it was
uh
they
didn't want anybody in that building and
there was only a limited amount of
people that could get in there
and
i'd say probably maybe 25 to 30 at the
most that were ever allowed in the
building
well you're standing this guard duty and
you're doing the best of your ability
which leads us to another life lesson
you have in here life lesson two your
life is significant so be excellent in
everything you do no matter how
insignificant you think your job is it
could turn out to be a life-changing
position one of the reasons captain dan
eventually selected me to be paired with
him was that during all the time i spent
pulling guard duty and training i never
complained but always did what was asked
of me i credit my dad for instilling
this attitude in my brothers and me he
always told us if you're gonna do
anything do your best
correct
that's an important one
uh you go on to say here as the member
as a member of the advanced party
another one of our tasks was to build
this large mock-up of buildings using
target canvas as the walls with doors
with cutouts for windows we began
constructing it on thursday september
10th and it took us several days to
complete we didn't know why we were
having to build it it wasn't until we
did our first walk through during our
initial training that i realized how it
would be used even then we had no idea
it was a dimensionally perfect replica
of all the buildings and walls of the
pow camp in sante north vietnam
so you guys built the full sized
two by fours or whatever jam two by
fours into the dirt and then build
little buildings yeah full-size
walk-throughs
it looked like toilet paper on a
wrapped on a uh two before so it
reminded me of you know but uh
and and one of the things we finally
clarified in in the book was everybody
said we used to take it down every night
well you know it took us a week to build
it and we weren't going to take that
down every night
because
the i mean we trained
most of our training was at night
and so there's no way we could take it
down and put it back up but uh and one
of the air force guys that actually
guarded it
uh i said that they've confirmed that
for us in the book and we were kind of
trying to find out who could we talk to
that
and the air force guy said no i said it
was even up after you guys left but they
did fly over it
and take pictures
right so they wanted to confirm that the
whatever the russians couldn't see it
from satellites or from flyovers and
aircraft or whatever exactly yep
but but somebody had started the rumor
that it was so secret that you would
take it down yeah all every day yeah
that's
exactly right
um
fast forward a little bit talking about
some of the training you do you you were
doing on wednesday september 9th about a
week after we arrived as the advanced
party the other 78 or so green berets
arrived and we started our training
the the first 30 days of training were
intense each day started with pt
followed by running the meadows mile
dick meadows loved to run and he led
many many of our runs now i like to run
but not like captain meadows if you are
not in shape you soon would be i think
this is one of the reasons i was
selected as one of the raiders i was by
no means the biggest man in fact i was
the second shortest the shortest raider
was also the oldest nco master sergeant
gallon pappy kittleson
pappy was no stranger to combat papi and
i had several things in common we were
both short and stocky built we'd both
grown up on a farm in the midwest in
world war ii pappy was the youngest man
in the raid on on the pow camp in the
philippines i was the youngest man on
this raid 25 years junior to pappy
[Laughter]
that's pretty awesome so he's he's what
45 then because you're 20. he's 45 years
old
and you're working with all these
legends with all this combat experience
and you know
what's interesting to me was none of
those guys ever let on like they were
greater than anybody else
i mean they were right there with us and
if you had a question that answered for
you and i mean they wanted to
and
i remember when we when we told the
packer bag we were leaving and we didn't
have a
at that time we didn't have a minister
or anything so pappy was a christian
and he said
i'm going to have a prayer service over
in the building if you guys want anybody
wants to come come and
when i walked in there i was amazed how
many of these guys that i didn't think
could spell god were there you know they
were on their knees praying and uh
and pappy was leading us and it
made an impression on me to
know that uh
you know you're not in control of
anything you just think you are and the
man upstairs is the one in charge
so
um
getting into some of this training
you say our training began with us
walking through our positions over and
over again in daylight during the first
month there were several changes to how
we performed our mission each person had
specific tasks to perform not only do we
have to know our own role but we had to
know the role of the man to our left and
right and where they would be when the
firing started captain dan and i were a
two-man team
as the rto for red wine security group
my job as captain dan put it i want you
at arm's length for me or i will be the
one to shoot you
and if you knew captain dan he would
have so you can bet i stayed damn close
to him the primary job of our two-man
team was to make our way to the
communications building as fast as we
could
to neutralize the people inside before
they could radio for reinforcements
we had two buildings to clear before we
could get to the communication building
the technique we used for clearing a
building was different from what our
troops used today as a two-man team we
would first toss a concussion grenade
into the building why use a concussion
grenade and not a frag grenade the
answer is very simple
the buildings were we were clearing of
bad guys were not made of concrete but
of a thin material that a piece of frag
would fly through captain dan would
stand to one side of the doorway and i
would position myself on the other side
across from him when the concussion
grenade exploded it would generally blow
the door open or in some cases
completely off as soon as the grenade
exploded captain dan would dive to the
floor at the threshold firing in the
room from the top left to the bottom
right at the same time i would step over
him
firing top right to bottom left by this
we created an x covering all the space
in the room captain dan would remain on
the floor and i would back out and shine
my flashlight into the room so captain
dan could confirm that we had
neutralized everyone i would then put in
a new clip depending on if i'd fired any
tracer rounds captain dan taught me that
in combat you don't have to you don't
have time to count how many bullets you
fired the technique is to first load
five treasure rounds and then finish
filling the magazine when you're in a
fire fight and you see tracers smoking
out the end of your barrel you know you
need to change magazines
that's a wild way to clear rules
and i gotta make a note here so when you
say concussion grenade so a lot of times
like we
what we use now we use something all the
time called a
crash grenade or a flash grenade or a
flash bang
and those create a boom
and a flash
but a concussion grenade is big it's a
different thing it's not the same as
it's not the same as a flashbang at all
it's a big in fact they're they're a lot
bigger than a frag grenade right they're
really big
and they create a massive explosion now
there's no fragmentation as you
mentioned right
but it is a massive explosion and when
you when that happens inside of a closed
room
you know even if the doors or the walls
aren't that strong
uh
it's going to create a
issue what did what did you think the
walls were going to be made of there in
the camp well we've we anticipated being
made just kind of like a thatch you know
maybe an adobe
the compound itself was kind of a brick
wall
but you know remember the french were in
there before
and we were there and
they had built the compound but the
buildings on the outside
were and the doors weren't really on
there as far as
the solid doors you know they were
uh pretty flimsy so you so you toss a
concussion grenade into the room
then
captain dan dives to the floor in the
doorway
and
unloads a magazine on full auto from the
top left to the bottom right while you
while he's doing that you straddle him
in the doorway and fire a full mag on
auto going top right to bottom left yep
this is that's this is serious business
it was our own technique
we were trying to figure out how to best
do it
this was dan's idea he said i'll hit the
floor you straddle me
and you know and then when you're
on fire this way you fire that away and
we'll create the x
and hopefully that would put everybody
down and but see our mission was not to
take pows right and we had to go through
that same area coming back
and we and bill simon said i don't want
anything holding us up so you neutralize
everybody on the way through and that
was our orders and that's what we did
and you know
the
our way of clearing a building is quite
different than the way they clear today
we didn't worry about the collateral
damage you know you were the bad guy and
that's what it was going to be so we
made sure that
we neutralized and moved on to the next
building
now were you worried about where you're
or did you guys plan in such a way that
your bullets
that were going through this building
that there was no friendlies on the
other side did you guys have the whole
thing kind of mapped out to avoid that
friendly fire yeah in fact even when the
choppers came in and took out the guard
towers
we made sure that we weren't shooting
into
one of the
cells
of the pows in fact
in order to do that
uh one of the
pjs said you know he could fire
and not hit the cell so what they did
they put a a sheet up
and tested him
and the guy
did exactly what he said he did i mean
he took out the guard tower but didn't
have anything near close to the cells
so when they when we flew in
in live mode uh that's what they did to
take out
a couple of the towers and then
there was one tower that we had
the blue boy had to take out because it
was in a situation where we didn't
couldn't fire into it and not think we
might hit a pow
so
that's
how we did things and
it was uh
it worked you know the only thing that
was bad about it is the hearing that uh
it uh
you know like you said those concussion
grenades are brutal and we didn't have
i had a headset and i had my headset
where one was on and one was off
but you know you stick your finger in
the ear and
hope that you could hear something but
after i came back it was for probably a
good couple of months i was just
and my hearing today is gone you know
from it and i
much of this from the
concussion grenade yes because i mean
the idea of the concussion is blow your
eyes not ears out yeah that's what it's
supposed to do is blow please with your
drums out yeah it does
and it does i can tell you
it's interesting because when i first
got in the seal teams we we didn't have
a very big budget and and some of the
training that we would do
for our kill houses that we would set up
they were just made of plywood
so it was actually harder in some ways
because you had to be aware of
where everyone else was in the house or
in the building because if you shot
around into a target or you missed the
target and we would have bullet traps
sometimes we'd have bullet traps but a
lot of times we'd be just be suiting
paper silhouette and so the bullet would
go through the whole house yeah and so
we had to organize these things that you
were all
kind of staying online even as you move
through a clearance of a building in
order to be safe and and then eventually
we ended up getting really nice
ballistic walls and then you get a lot
it's a lot easier to do and luckily
where we were fighting
in iraq most of the time you know it was
it was concrete walls or whatever um so
you could you could actually shoot in
rooms and they wouldn't generally go
through the walls but it takes a
different level of planning when you
have to account for
your rounds just continuing downrange
even pass through you know the building
that you're in yeah i mean the
collateral damage on something like that
could be pretty high if if
yeah done wrong i mean when i when we
got uh terry buck and lieutenant dan
spraying 30 round mags if the if you
don't if you don't have a good plan
that's gonna you're gonna shoot your own
people so you guys had to think through
a lot of these things in a lot of detail
and the good thing is where you were
training was the same thing it wasn't
like you were training a ballistic house
you were shooting through
uh you know just just uh whatever paper
or whatever cloth yeah exactly
from all this training you put together
uh life lesson three
you say in your work always be training
and improving during the first month of
our training there were several changes
made to how we approached our positions
i learned a very important lesson invest
timing time and training it pays off
just like a football team trains for the
big game we were training for our big
game the major difference our lives
depended on how well we performed
training sometimes gets boring but when
the bullets start flying in both
directions
you're sure glad
that you know what is expected of you
and your team members
and you know
that that probably
is one of the more
important messages
that i think
could come out of this book because
i think the training that we did saved
our lives
because we had
i mean we had 177 rehearsals
and
part of those were alternate you know
like if red wine went down it was red
wine alternate red wine green leaf went
down it was alternate green leaf
when we were sitting down
that night in sante
and i'm listening on my radio
and i'm hearing alternate playing green
and you think the [__] factor didn't
jump up then because you just lost one
third we'll get to it but that at that
moment you lost one third of your
assault force but our training and the
training that we did paid off
in spades because we
we knew how to react and it wasn't like
oh now what do we do we know what to do
we train for it
and
the the planners of this sante
have done such an immaculate job of
thinking of all the different
scenarios
the only one they didn't think about was
the pows not being there that was the
one that we just i mean floored
everybody yeah but uh yeah and even i
thought through that and we'll get to
the actual raid itself but as much
planning went into it
and as much they tried to think of all
the different scenarios that could take
place
something happened that they didn't plan
for which is
what is it green leaf green leaf
came back to the target site so you had
to do a link up which is one of the
hardest things to do in a combat zone is
linking up with friendly forces in fact
i think it's the hardest thing to do the
hardest thing to do in combat is link up
with friendly forces
and particularly like they they got off
just like we did
anything in front of you is open game
yeah and you know we were
and for a few minutes there it got
pretty testy and uh
you know
i i have to compliment some of the the
guys that were on green leaf you know
they they knew they were coming back in
on a hot lz
but they also knew that you know uh
there's friendly guys out in front too
and uh they had to restrain themselves
you know absolutely it was it was a
pretty good uh yeah
and they were coming from a firefight
themselves exactly so they got hot
weapons they're they're amped up they
hear you guys shooting 400 yards away
now they're landing their helicopters
and and so it's a testament to the
training not just to the rehearsal of
hey this is exactly what's going to
happen and here's the contingency plan
but here's something that we didn't
expect to happen exactly but we still
have the good standard operating
procedures the presence of mind to make
to make the right decisions and that's a
testament to all this training oh it was
i mean and that's that's when i speak to
military groups today i said i know we
all hate to train but i can tell you i
am living proof that what they we
trained on probably saved a bunch of
lives yeah and
awesome life lesson um
going back to the book here you said as
one of the six guys assigned to guard
the tactical operation center i started
to see that i might miss out on some of
the key training if i wanted to have a
chance of getting selected for one of
the assault force teams i had to train
when i was not pulling guard duty
security was so tight that we didn't
know who we would be rescuing or in what
part of the world the mission would take
place there was a lot of speculation
that it might be an attempt to free
prisoners in cuba based on the
three-hour flying time of the mission i
had been training and pulling guard duty
for about a month when i got my chance
to speak up i was checking colonel
bill's cole simons
for access to the talk building
while we were waiting for an escort to
take the bull in
he asked how things were going for me
i knew that he was only going to pick
some of us for the actual mission so i
said sir i didn't volunteer to come here
and pull guard duty if i wanted to pull
guard duty i would have stayed at fort
bragg
now bull always had a two inch cigar
that he chewed on he looked me right in
the eyes and said young man hang in
there things are going to change pretty
soon after that he went into the
building i thought to myself what the
hell did i just do first i chewed out
two sergeant majors back at fort bragg
trying to get on this mission now i just
told a colonel and not just any colonel
but bull simons that i was tired of
pulling guard duty i i just bitched to
the bull about pulling guard duty
i thought well i'll probably end up
pulling guard duty for the rest of my
time in the army
however what he said was true within the
next week things did change
the first cut was made on friday
september 18th they selected 51 men and
an additional 10 men were identified as
backup that could be used in any of the
different elements i was selected to be
a part of the red wine security group i
would be the rto for captain dan turner
no more guard duty for me the three
groups were each placed in their own
areas in the barracks building to help
the team concept
you know why do you think you got
selected
um i i sent an email to dan turner
dennis passed away but uh before he
passed away i sent him an email asking
him that
and
he
he said basically i didn't [__] about
whatever i was asked to do and he said
you always had a
great attitude that you know i could do
that and whether i could do it or not
i i took the attitude that i could get
it done
and he just
felt like i
i was older than the 20 year old
that he
was accustomed to
so and i think that's
attributed to just growing up in a farm
and
you know you you do things that uh
you know i started driving a tractor
when i was six years old you know
and you know it was
just i had had to keep it between the
bales of hay
when we were picking up hay and that was
about it you know but that's
you do things
on a farm back in those days that you
wouldn't have thought about doing
but
um that was
i was confident that i could
do the right job for him and
hopefully uh i did
this also leads to another life lesson
life lesson number four you say have
patience and aggressiveness and
contentment guarding the talk we are not
allowed to know the why
as i saw my opportunity slipping away i
was aggressive hungry to be in the
middle of the action that's okay it's
not a fault to be aggressive it's a
virtue
if you can choose in your heart and in
your mind to be at peace and to be
thankful trusting god with the outcome
so you gotta know you gotta be patient
at the same time you you know you
sometimes you gotta approach uh
the bull yeah
yeah
yeah and he he uh
i could tell he wasn't offended by it
you know he just
he asked the question and i thought
here's my opportunity to tell him you
know and if he said anything
i just gotta
go with it and
i mean that's what you're looking for
when you're in charge of a team you want
someone that wants to go that wants to
step up and that's the impression you
gave him for sure
um you say in in our training at fort
bragg we used blanks but for our
training here at auxiliary field three
we used live ammunition i remember one
day we were throwing frag grenades and
one of the guys got hit with some
shrapnel it was only a minor cut but it
drove home the point that we needed to
stay sharp by the end of the first month
we had practiced until every person knew
not only his own position but also the
job of every person around him and
the alternate plans
then
we started practicing at night
this is a serious rehearsals going on
um
you go on to say when we first started
training using the helicopters the plan
called for captain dan to be the first
man off and for me to be the second now
i had watched enough war movies to know
that the first men off any vehicle get
killed for a couple of weeks we trained
this way i thought oh [__] we aren't
even gonna make it off the chopper i can
now admit that every time i stepped off
stepped off the chopper the thought went
through my mind of getting zapped before
my foot even hit the ground
then after a few rehearsals the plan
changed to where captain dan and i were
the last two off the chopper all of a
sudden i thought damn now that i'm the
last guy off the bad guys will have
their sights locked on i will get nailed
for sure eventually i had to admit that
if the good lord wants me he doesn't
care from the first the last or the
middle my maker is going to bring me
home when it's my time
that's uh some good young paranoia right
either way you're getting shot that's
right
you say life lesson five this is an
important one be prepared for death
don't worry about it you can't
completely control it
make sure that the day you meet your
maker is not the first time you've been
introduced
if you are prepared at all times you're
free to live life fearless and that was
your attitude eventually you had to say
you know what whether i'm first whether
i'm last if it's my time it's my time i
can only control so much
and you know
that point was really driven home last
week when my wife passed away that
you know
she she
was prepared to meet her maker i know
that
and
she's in a better place today because of
that so
it holds true in my mind
so
um well i mean it's it's a testament
when you can say that
you know that your wife who lived a
amazing life
and and
she passed away
and you know we were talking before
we we started that you said well we're
going to come out here anyways we're
going to record this thing because she
would want me to carry on with the
mission yep exactly
um
yeah it's a it's a it's an important
part of the book you know and
i think that i think that happens with
young guys going into combat
you have to get to a point where you say
man you know what
this could
i could die tonight yeah and but you
could do that walking across a road you
could do that walking across the road
and you you can only control the things
you control you can train hard
you can prepare you can study the plan
you can mitigate the risk but there's
some risk you're not gonna be able to
mitigate right
and if you concentrate on those things
it's gonna drive you crazy that's gonna
say it takes away from everything else
yeah exactly
um
you talk more about some of the training
that you did again you got to buy the
book to get all all the details
you talk about uh some of the friday
night fights which was they would bring
like a band and and
booze and women and they had like a bar
set up
and so you do that on friday nights and
again it's crazy to think that you guys
still didn't know where you were going
you guys had no idea where you're going
you thought you might be going to cuba
i think there was somewhere else you
thought you might be going there were
planes hijacked on tarmacs around the
world that we thought we might be going
in to
rescue you know people on hijacked
planes so you have no idea what you're
doing no which
and everybody you know it was we didn't
know we just knew we were going to do
some type of rescue
and we trained
for it
and did you know that it was real
so no okay because i know sometimes we
would get spun up in such a way where
they'd be like hey we got a mission and
we think actually this the very first
deployment i went on
we got recalled we had little beepers
and i was in guam and we had beepers and
they said hey if this thing shows up
9-1-1 you know you got
20 minutes to get to base because
something's going on
so we get there and i'm i'm
well i'm i guess i'm 19 or 20 at this
point
maybe i'm 20 or 21 but anyways i'm young
and very dumb
and i also think that i'm you know i
think i'm going to vietnam you know i
think i'm i think i'm going to be like
the combination of james bond and rambo
and everybody else
so we show up in guam on deployment my
paseo platoon
it's
1992 or 1993 anyways
but i think there's just you know this
is it we're going to war
so we go out we get all we go out to the
range we get all of our weapons dialed
in and i'm just
totally ready
and then
um i'm doing something and i get that
the 911 on my pager and um oh there you
go here it is it's on it's go time
and we run you know rush into back to
base we're sitting on our platoon space
and my leading petty officer comes in
and says
hey they went and inspected the range we
didn't do a good job cleaning up
we got to go clean up our brass
[Laughter]
so uh yeah
not exactly what i anticipated yeah
bud um it's funny yeah yeah
uh so you guys are doing this friday
night oh my point was that
we we would sometimes get recalled to do
something and they wouldn't tell us it
was training
until
like we were ready to launch or and we
some guys would know some guys they go
this is just training but of course i'd
be like no way man it's real you know
um but you guys so did some of you think
maybe this is just a big training
operation uh in the beginning we kind of
did
but uh with bull being in charge
and all the you know we saw
a lot of
brass around us you know this was the
first mission ever
to be under the direct control the joint
chiefs of staff we didn't know that at
the time either
i mean we we knew that
there was guys in washington coming down
every once in a while and they would go
into the building and we'd think why are
they there you know but you know nobody
ever explained to us that you know they
were doing the same thing up in
washington dc but uh
it was it was a uh
we we just
kind of kept in the dark and fed on
[__] that's what we were and
that's the way it started and
uh we were just told to do our job yeah
and that's what we were doing
speaking of friday night fights you say
there's one in one uh interesting
incident that sticks in my mind our
barracks were two stories world war ii
style with one big open bay for all of
us i was on the first floor and our beds
were lined up on each side of the room
it was about 1 30 a.m when i was
awakened by crashing noises just four
bunks down from mine it was three ncos
wrestling a master sergeant to the floor
in our barracks apparently the master
sergeant after quite a few drinks had a
disagreement with bull simons at the bar
concerning how the team should perform
their mission and was frustrated that
the troops were being kept in the dark
the discussion got heated and the nco
came back to his barracks to get his
weapon to persuade the good colonel to
use his ideas the guys in the barracks
held the nco until he eventually cooled
down the next morning the bull and the
nco were on the pt field the bull had
the nco heels locked at attention while
he chewed his butt up one side and down
the other the bull convinced him that he
should not disagree with him again at
least not with a threat of bodily harm
but the bull did not let this affect his
relationship with the nco or anybody
else the bull always said he didn't want
a bunch of boy scouts we always look
forward to friday night fights and this
is classic the following entry was made
into the official talk record of events
i believe this is the very discussion
with that master sergeant and so this is
a quote from the actual record it says
27 october
1715 colonel simon's discussed
grievances with operational personnel
and disgust progress end quote
yeah that was uh
that was an interesting evening and more
importantly the next day we were we were
all looking out the window thinking well
wouldn't you like to be a little mouse
hearing what that conversation's about
but
i mean it was over and
he went on the mission with us and
he
but the bull said you know he didn't
want boy scouts and yeah he didn't have
any yeah
yeah i know as a leader you want to have
guys that are going to push back if they
disagree with you because you might have
a bad idea yeah um now you don't want
them to go to their barracks and try and
grab a weapon
to convince you
but you do want to hear their hear what
they're going to say and what why they
think that you know um
fast forward a little bit
monday november 16 1970.
we were told to pack our gear that we
were leaving eglin air force base for
our new undisclosed location the next
day we didn't have a chaplain to our
group in our group but we did have
pappy pappy announced that he would be
holding a prayer service in the barracks
papi was respected by all the raiders
and officers from the bull
down the chain of command in world war
ii papi had been an alamo scout just
like paul simon's they had both been on
the raid that freed 500 pows
there's a 2005 major motion picture
called the great raid papi was pretty
famous in the army particularly in
special forces when i walked into the
barracks where pappy was holding the
prayer service it really struck me how
many of these seasoned soldiers were
there to pray on their knees to our
father in heaven i can tell you there
were no atheists in our group
the next morning you guys get on board
c-141
first place you land is california next
place you land is alaska and you still
don't know where you're going no they
still have not told you where you're
going
the next stop would be our new home for
a few days it was a long flight we
didn't get much sleep but at least we
touched down at our final destination it
was november 18th at 3 a.m when we
stopped
when we stepped off the c-140 directly
into a large hangar they loaded us into
what would what i thought were bread
trucks the air in this dark land had a
sweet tropical smell warm and humid the
old warriors thought we were in
southeast asia but we're not certain
we never knew it until many years later
but this was the cia compound at the
tackley is it saying that right tackley
royal thai air force base when our
trucks arrived at some barracks most of
us went straight to bed our trip had
taken 28 hours
so you even know where you are
no and some of the old-timers are
thinking hey it kind of smells like
southeast asia that's about all i got
yep that's that's right
uh we were awakened at 6am had breakfast
it went about our morning as normal we
were told to be at the mess hall at 11
a.m a little earlier than normal lunch
during lunch we were told to go to our
barracks immediately after we finish
eating and get some sleep
to ensure we got some sleep lieutenant
colonel joe cataldo our doctor who would
be going on the mission and into the
compound with us required every one of
us to take a sleeping pill as we exited
the mess hall as we walked toward the
barracks the old timers explained that
they had never had to do that before it
was pretty clear that this would be the
night
i spent the rest of the afternoon
walking around the compound and talking
to the other raiders about what they
thought was going on the time passed
very slowly that afternoon by 5 pm
everyone was awakened from our bunks and
told to get to the mess hall for dinner
then meet in the theater at 1800.
by 1730 we started filling the theater
you could tell everyone was getting
pumped for what we were about to learn
and this is where you get the uh the
speech that i opened this whole thing up
with where you finally find out
where you're where you're actually going
because you had no idea and that
the the way you write about that that
reaction that everybody had
would you say i mean i would imagine
that all these other possible missions
that you could be going on there would
be none more
favorable
than going to actually rescue other
american service members in vietnam i
mean that's yep that's the that's the
pinnacle yeah that's what we thought too
i mean we were ready to
had they been there they'd have been
home that night
all 70
or more
um
so you get that speech
you say at 2100 the bread trucks took us
to a hangar that we used as our staging
area we checked our weapons i carried a
colt m1911 a 45 caliber pistol my
machine gun was a car 15 with eight 20
round magazines and five 30 round
magazines i used the tips i'd learned
from captain dan on how i should load my
magazines i strapped on two frag
grenades and 10 concussion grenades
captain dan told me that if we ended up
needing to use frags well we were
probably in some deep [__] so i hoped i
did not have to use them
we used the concussion grenades inc in
clearing the buildings my next task was
to check the batteries on both my radios
i checked my handset and my headset on
my prick 25
that's the way we were we were to
communicate with lieutenant colonel
sidner's ground command team the headset
allowed me to listen to the radio
traffic and still fire my weapon and
toss grenades
each raider carried carried a survival
radio a prick 90.
when you turn on these radios they send
out a warble tone that allows our search
and rescue team to pull you out of a hot
situation
among the 56 raider raiders we had 92
radios
so you're getting your gear ready
and you go through some you gets pretty
cool in here you know for people that
are going to get the book which i'm sure
is a lot
uh you go through like a gear list of
absolutely everything that you're
carrying every all the specialty gear
that you had
um
the chainsaw
chainsaws the guys were carrying welder
uh
arc welders which even though despite
your incredible welding skills you
didn't get assigned
they assigned it to somebody else tiny
tiny was
probably about no six two six three oh
yeah he could hoax that was pretty easy
but nobody wanted to be around tiny he'd
get shot if those tanks get shot it's
gonna be a disaster
time to go
c130 landed at udorn at 2300 ushered out
you guys are ushered out to your hh53
choppers
and here we go at 2317 with all the
green berets aboard apple ii lifted off
forming up with the other five
helicopters and lime 1 and lime 2 the 4
engine c130 hercules tankers that would
take us to the border of north vietnam
during our training we had only made the
full three hour long flight twice the
idea
i think was to keep us from trying to
figure out where we might be going what
i remember about that night was how hot
it was and ha and that the sky was very
clear
on that long chopper flight from eudoran
to sante i spent a lot of time in prayer
you can learn a little bit about
yourself seeing what your mind latches
onto when you know that in a few hours
you might be meeting your maker
god has an important part god has been
important part of my life as long as i
can remember my mother's side of the
family attended church pretty regularly
compared to my dad's side the bucklers
like to drink dance and party not to say
they don't believe in god they just like
to celebrate a little bit more
after about an hour of flying most of
the guys were lying back against the
sides of the chopper some guys had their
eyes closed either praying or sleeping i
thought to myself these men are true
warriors many of the raiders were
married some had kids my age or older
there was a lot of small talk i figured
each man was thinking there was not a
lot of small talk i figured each man was
thinking of his family each one knew the
risk he was taking we were no different
than other warriors before us our
military is filled with men and women
who are willing to risk their lives to
protect this great country
i sat back and had a nice little talk
with the big man upstairs i asked and
protect to protect us tonight
it was the longest three hours i had
ever experienced i thought about my mom
and dad and how they would feel if i
didn't make it back i wondered what they
would think when they read the letter
i'd written to them before i left i
thought about what my dad told me before
i left for the army don't volunteer for
anything
so what did i do i volunteered for
airborne then special forces and now for
this raid
i thought mom and dad would be heading
to moose lodge this weekend for a
saturday outing i thought about doug my
oldest brother who served in the navy
submarines for nine years i thought
about how my brothers and i fought and
the crazy things we had done on the farm
i thought about the times i hunted
squirrels with dad i thought back to the
first squirrel i killed i shot him about
nine times and when dad and i were
skinning it he said we might get lead
poisoning when we eat this one
i thought about my buddy charlie
cottingham and the fun we had as kids i
thought back to the times mike and i
spent riding our horses into the woods
around our farms i guess i was trying to
take my mind off the mission
because i couldn't stop mentally
rehearsing
my duties for the mission over and over
and over
i got up to stretch my legs and look out
the window i would could see the other
choppers in the moonlight it was like we
were doing
just another rehearsal so prepared we
were
but this was the live run we were
actually going in
i sat back down and said another prayer
for us and waited for us to arrive at
sante north vietnam
it's a long flight that's a long flight
to be sitting there thinking about this
target that you're going into yep it
certainly was
were you and there's so many details in
this book that i'm not covering uh
because i don't want to read the entire
book but
how well aware were you of the
possibility of surface-to-air missiles
well we knew they
had brought
several of our pilots down
but we weren't
that wasn't on our mind
you know we were grunts on the ground so
that you know
sams don't affect us
until we had one fired at us
and we realized just how damn
close it got
so you guys were blessed with a little
bit of
or at least you were of being a little
bit naive yes
and and i know that we've
we've lost a lot of our naive
attitude about helicopters because we've
we've taken some some
horrific hits in helicopters and lost a
ton of incredibly
great people yep but but for you guys
you weren't really thinking about that
too much you weren't
and and you knew we we knew we had air
cover with the a1es
and uh you know we had a1e flying over
us all the time when we run the compound
so
the bridge we were supposed to blow it
because of the alternate we didn't
blow it but the a1e took out
uh the bridge force so
we knew we had good cover there
and then of course we weren't that aware
of what was going on at the same time
uh from the gulf of talking you know
there was 116 aircraft coming in
which um
i mean that's
the largest air raid in vietnam history
did they brief you guys on any of that
no
we had no idea about it till we got back
because they had basically set up a
massive diversionary operation yes on
the other side of hanoi right to to
distract from what you guys were doing
and i and i think it really worked if
you you know some of the after-action
reports that came back
uh said that you know some of the and
the migs didn't even get off the ground
because they were confused as
where they were coming from and you know
we were dropping flares
over hanoi and
while we were sneaking in the backside
to sante so all their attention was
coming from the gulf of token
and
there was a sam site just south of us
and anti-aircraft as well
i mean i think we had a total of 20 sams
fired at us
that night
and uh one of them the first one
the first and the only one i really
remember
was the one when we
we had landed
done our deal and we were coming out
and
we got on the
bird
and we our account was off
you know so we did another count
it was still off and then so we did a
third count and this time dan turner
counted himself
which was
kind of
in the excitement i guess you know but
anyway so we we got up and we
we were sitting there we had a pj
between us and dan and i were on both
sides of the tail
as we were leaving
north vietnam
and
the
chopper as it turned and we were looking
over the lights of hanoi just like you'd
be looking over the lights here in san
diego i mean couldn't believe how big it
was
and then
we were flying we thought well we got it
made you know we're back on the boat
and we're heading home and about that
time
our chopper just dropped and we thought
oh
we got hit or something and about that
time big
uh
looked like a light pole flying up our
rear
and it probably missed us by i would say
no more than 200 meters
it was i mean it was close
and
of course our pilots we had the very
best pilots the air force had those guys
i swear they
they did a fantastic job of getting us
in and getting us out and uh
it was
it was a little bit that's where that's
where i really got scared honestly
because you know
i kind of had control of everything on
the ground but when you're up there i
was pilots man
i have a lot of respect for those guys
they're sitting ducks
and uh
you know they uh
and we lost one uh not a one of the
choppers but one of the
jets
was taken out by that night
but the pilots were recovered the next
morning so
but uh it just shows you how quick it
can happen
as you're going in are you thinking what
are you thinking your chances are
yeah you know uh
my my thoughts were
okay the good lord is
with me and with us
and we're going to be all right but i
got to do my doing whatever it takes you
know
one of my biggest fears was
would i freeze
you know having never been in combat you
know i mean i've heard of guys have been
in combat before freezing
even guys have been in for a long time
you know but
that was a concern of mine would i be
able to but all the old-timers kept
coming up to me and said don't hesitate
don't hesitate whatever you do don't
hesitate was there anyone else that had
no combat experience uh there was four
of us that had never been in combat
before wow yeah
and out of how many out of 56
four of us and never been in combat so
it was an
eye-opening experience and
uh
the dan turner told me one time
afterwards jesus you saw more combat
than i saw in a year in vietnam i said
really it goes oh yeah
so
um
so here we go
0-20
saturday november 21st 1970
when we were just about to la land i
heard through the chatter in my headset
the voice of sergeant first class howell
came through he was the rto for
lieutenant colonel sidner the ground
force commander for the raid
alternate plan green i repeat alternate
plan green do you copy
this was only the first of the bad news
i would hear tonight
i responded say again
sergeant first class howell
alternate plan green alternate plan
green over
i said back into my hand mike roger
alternate plan green over
i thought to myself holy crap this can't
be real i turned to captain dan and told
him we were going to alternate plan
green captain dan gave me that oh [__]
look and calmly told me to pass the
announcement onto others in red wine
alternate plan green meant one thing to
all of us on the red wine chopper we
knew that we had 22 fewer men there
would be a lot less firepower as we hit
the ground whether green leaf group had
mechanical problems or had been shot
down we knew the mission including the
alternate plans with that with or
without the 22 men of green leaf group
we were going to execute the mission and
would now have to perform their role as
well as ours so what had happened here
and again you go into these details in
the book but
greenleaf this one other chopper
had landed in the wrong spot uh there
was a school yard that was
400 yards to the south
and it looked kind of like the pow camp
campaign a little school compound right
and that's where they landed
um
the colonel colonel bull simons was with
them yes
so you get this call that hey we're
going so we're still going they're in
the wrong spot but we're still going you
still need to execute the mission and
this is where you have life lesson
number six don't be indispensable
always be training a backup person for
your job and always be learning to be a
backup for your teammates this applies
to any job in life the graveyards are
full of indispensable men
but uh yeah that's a sketchy situation
all of a sudden you got one-third the
troops
and as this is happening i'm going back
the book at that moment the mini gun in
the door to our right fired off a few
hundred rounds for those of you not
familiar with the minigun it's a gun
that fires four thousand rounds of ammo
per minute it has been
it is electronically driven rotary
breach to feed the ammo belt at
lightning speed now my heart was already
pounding but the sound of that mini gun
firing two feet from me really took me
to a new level i adjust my headset on
the prick 25 on my back and feel for my
ammo pouches i check for frags and my
concussion grenades i place my finger on
the safety and make sure i have the
safety off and my car 15 is set on auto
i make sure to have the 30 round
magazine well seated and i chamber
around in training i've done this a
hundred times but this is it
my first time in combat this is no game
i'm not as scared as much as i am
excited this is the moment i have
trained for the reason i joined the
green berets i don't i can't let captain
dan down or the other raiders as the rto
for the red wine security group my job
is to stay close to captain dan he's the
commander of red wine and i am expected
to protect his backside
the tailgate is lowered the chopper is
feathering to the ground we are about to
touch down on the enemy's homeland and
there is no rescuing us if there has
been a security breach i feel the
choppers settle as it is done so many
times in training red wine group is
unloading exactly as we have practiced
over 170 times the major difference is
that this time the bullets are flying in
both directions
it is amazing how fast you can exit a
chopper captain dan and i start off the
tale of the chapter the last two men off
i am literally one step to his right
side as we run our boots have just
started splashing the rice paddies when
a north vietnamese army soldier fires at
us from the very building we were to
clear
a couple of bullets zip by us a natural
reaction i place the green dot from my
armalite single point site on the
guard's chest and fire three rounds he
immediately falls to the ground in that
instant i don't hesitate what the season
warriors taught me really paid off don't
hesitate
i imagine most of the warriors
in your first time downrange wonder in
the back of your mind how you will
respond in that moment would i freeze
when i faced with the decision to kill
or be killed i had only just stepped
onto the enemy's ground and i had my
first kill
there'd be more to come as we cleared
the buildings
out of the gate
you know i watch a lot of uh
fighting
and they always talk about you know
who's got the fastest record knockout in
a fight
you might have the fastest kill on enemy
territory that you step off and you're
immediately engaging a guy
that's kind of crazy to think about yeah
it is i hadn't thought about it that way
but
yeah
uh you go on captain dan thanks me as we
charge towards our first building i am
following captain dan with bullets
blazing and men moving to their
positions alternate plan green is
proceeding we hear our chopper apple ii
loudly lift off the rice paddies to wait
about a mile away until they are called
back in to take us home with the pows we
came to free in the back of our minds if
these birds get battle damage it will be
a long way back to friendly lines no
time to think about that
we move forward to clear our designated
buildings nearest
nearest to us master sergeant joe lupiak
and his red wine element two which
includes him sergeant first class tyrone
adderley and sergeant first class billy
martin each of us knew this was going to
be much more difficult than it was
during training these are buildings that
greenleaf group would have neutralized
according to the original plan and they
would have had 14 of their men on this
task
under alternate plan green
five of our team were now going to have
to do it
they also had more firepower sergeant
first class jake jacovenko was carrying
an m60 bipod machine gun which we don't
have on our team
what we did still have was the element
of surprise bull simons told us if there
was a security leak we would know it by
the time the second chopper landed
we turned out to be that second chopper
and we are operating like a well-oiled
machine
captain dan is redirecting our red wine
group comprised of four elements and it
is made and is making sure we are
getting the job done as as a virgin to
combat and as captain dan's rto i stay
close to him you have to respect and
trust the men with whom you go to battle
this is where the months of training
pay off
we know what we have to do next
alternate plan green means that the
bridge north of the pow camp will remain
open to enemy reinforcements crossing it
since we didn't have enough raiders to
send someone to blow it over the radios
lieutenant colonel sidner directs the
a1e skyraider pilots to light it up with
rockeye missiles if anyone tries to
cross at the a1s we'll open up with 20
millimeter cannon those flyboys are
cocky but damn they're good at their job
what amazes me is that in all this chaos
the only one of us only one green beret
gets wounded
that is sergeant first class joe murray
joe is a member of master sergeant
herman spencer's team
whose job is it is to secure the area
south of the south wall
that's the wall closest to where the
helicopters dropped us off and will
later pick us up master sergeant spencer
is carrying a 40-pound block of c4
explosives slung over his shoulder it is
to be used to blow the bridge it turned
out to be a good shield for him as we
landed and spilled out of our
helicopters spencer and murray
immediately rushed towards their
objective the guard shack by the south
wall spencer took a couple rounds from a
guard with an ak-47 in the block of c4
he was carrying
joe murray would not be that lucky
that's something that surprises people
is that c4 is relatively stable when
it's when it's by itself right
that's why you have blasting caps
or detonation cord because those things
will blow up and then they make the c4
blow up right
but c4 by itself is relatively stable
yeah
um
back to the book when spencer was
dealing with that guard
that delayed spencer just such that joe
arrives at the guard shack alone the
building needs to be cleared immediately
before the enemy troops inside can all
emerge so joe decides to use a frag
grenade instead of a concussion grenade
as he is about to toss in the window he
feels his leg push forward with a
burning sensation joe tosses the frag
grenade in neutralizing the guard shack
he then turns to eliminate the threat
spencer now arriving fires his machine
gun first and eliminates three guards
joe is the only army raider to receive a
purple heart
that's crazy that's
and there's like
is there just uh a massive amount of
gunfire at this point yeah yeah it's
uh everybody's letting loose with
everything they got
you know and and you have one guy get
hit in the leg yeah
the back back of his leg
um
going on for captain dan and me the
objective is to get to the communication
buildings as fast as possible to prevent
them from calling for reinforcements
it's a good 50 meters ahead of us and
it's an open area with no cover we have
two buildings to clear before we clear
the communications building we were told
that we would not take any north
vietnamese army prisoners and neutralize
everyone
we will be coming back through the same
area and bull doesn't want anyone
preventing us from getting back to the
choppers to do this we have to ensure
that there is no one alive to ambush us
on our way back
captain dan and i are getting closer to
the communications building we can see
the main guard houses on fire and people
are running away from us clearing the
main guard house was the job of another
red wine element and they apparently are
succeeding
we still have two more buildings to
clear the first one is empty the second
one has a few north vietnamese army
soldiers i toss a concussion grenade
into the room and as soon as it explodes
captain dan drops the floor and i stand
in the door straddling him we create a
crossfire with me firing fully automatic
from right to left and he from left to
right he yells clear and i back out and
shine my flashlight so he can confirm
we've neutralized everyone
because there are a number of them we do
a closer check that they are all
neutralized
in the clearing of the buildings at
sante captain dan and i are the only
two-man team depending on how close you
are to the grenade when it explodes it
can bust your eardrums and pretty well
mess you up and building 12 as i'm
confirming everyone is dead it's a grim
task whatever you're thinking right now
it is far more grim than that a guard
raises his weapon behind me
captain dan neutralizes him there is no
doubt with that decisive action captain
dan saved my life
so you're sitting you're going through
the buildings are you just doing
security rounds in these guys yeah and
then one of them that you haven't gotten
to yet
we just you know
we just put a bullet in everybody's head
and made sure and while you're doing
that one of those guys that you hadn't
gotten to yet yep
decides he's gonna take a shot at you
yeah and captain dan sees him and kills
him yeah i had my back to him when he
did it
and when dan fired scared me
i thought i thought somebody was
shooting you know but it was it was dan
shooting all right but
shooting the guy that
was going to take me out so
approaching zero two two eight
lieutenant colonel sidner received
notification that green leaf group is
not out of commission
we can hear apple one landing and are
told to hold fast until green leaf
elements get to their original planned
positions with 22 men of green leaf team
including bull simons we are back on
track within one minute green leaf has
secured the guard quarters per the plan
and takes over their roles that the red
wine
team members have been handling for them
again that's a comp that seems real easy
but when you got all this shooting going
on and now you got friendlies moving
into positions where there's other
friendlies and you got enemy shooting at
you that this is a sketchy thing it was
very intense
right there and we were kind of away
from it because we were we were going
towards the communication building and
over here was where they were coming
from of course you know
adelie was he had a m79 grenade launcher
so he was booping them right in the
windows
and
he you know whole kentucky win he's
worked real well for him
in fact tyrone is getting the bull
simon's award from socom oh i'll send
may outstanding yeah so well deserved
yeah that's outstanding
uh
you go on here at 0-229 we had just
reached the communication buildings when
i heard on my headset
negative items
i told captain dan he asked me are you
sure
items was the code word for pows
it didn't make any sense the next radio
call i heard was at 0-230 begin
extraction to choppers we entered the
communication buildings without tossing
a grenade it was empty
at this time we started to move back to
the lz for extraction we still moved
with the assumption that there could be
more enemy soldiers lying in the bushes
while the helicopters were in route
returning to extract us
one of red wine's roles was to clear the
planned lz by cutting down certain light
poles that task revealed one frustrating
surprise we had brought a chainsaw to
cut down certain wooden telephone poles
but sergeant first class charles mastin
and sergeant first class ronnie strahan
were to blow up a tall concrete light
pole
the moment that maston and strahan
finished placing the four one pound
packets of c4 explosive were ready to
blow and were conforming confirming that
they should actually activate the fuse
apple one was arriving
they waited until apple wanted landed
offloaded green leaf and departed
ensured of safety they detonated the c4
as the pole rose into the air a huge
flash of light mastin and strahan could
see that this was not a light pole it
had four large high tension power lines
dancing sparks were everywhere as the
four huge power lines hit the rice
paddies the very rice paddies in which
our soldiers and pows would be
marshaling to load the returning
choppers
we were going to have to find a new
location were we going to have to find a
new location for the lz mastin strahan
and captain jim mclamb as the
marshalling area control officer
immediately set about ensuring they
understood the location of all the lines
and whether they were hot after
assessing the situation and ensuring
there were no other potential hazards
they began placing the bean bag lights
in an area suitably distant from the
power lines
as everyone returned to the lz waiting
for the helicopters we had a few minutes
to gather people and equipment to load
on apple 1 and apple 2.
you snuck one of your life lessons in
here
don't be a complainer the world is
moving on and needs people to solve
problems evaluate your situation make a
decision and execute any new plan
without complaining and feel sorry for
yourself
it's not going to help
not going to help the situation you got
to make things happen exactly
no pows was not something we had spent
time thinking about i could hear chatter
on my headset i heard the rto for bull
say that bull was coming into the
compound bull had to verify with his own
eyes that there were no pows
at 0-237 apple one landed facing east
toward hanoi and loaded red wine group
and blue boy group captain dan and i
were the last ones to board the two of
us sat in the tail of the chopper
loading the door fully down and open
with a mini gun mounted right between us
manned by an air force pj
at 0-240 we lifted off and turned west
looking out of the tail
we had a front row seat with a bird's
eye view of hanoi i will never forget
that view
i couldn't believe how big hanoi was and
how close we were to it it looked like
any major city in america we were only
about 20 miles from the capital of north
vietnam
never before had the north vietnamese
army been violated like this that's when
it really hit me what we had just done
we were rising only a minute or two
after liftoff suddenly our chopper took
a hard dive to the left what looked like
a telephone pole with a bright red
fireball shot by us i yelled over to
captain dan what the hell was that
before he could answer the gunner
standing between us yelled that it was a
surface-to-air missile a sam
now i was scared while i was on the
ground but now i was really scared
and this is what you were talking about
before on the ground i have a fighting
chance but being in a chopper at 600
feet you feel like a sitting duck thank
god for some of the best pilots we could
have these guys knew how to handle it we
were soon out from the threat into the
dark jungle mountains and headed for
udorn
during the next three hours on the
flight back to base i had plenty of time
to replay what we had done that night
like the rest of the raiders i was very
disappointed that we came home with no
pows i kept thinking what went wrong why
when
when had the pows been removed
that flight returning to udon seemed a
lot longer than the flight to sante
we've been so pumped up about our
mission to find no pows was the last
thing that would have ever crossed our
mind beyond the two wounds received
u.s air force tech sergeant leroy
wright's ankle was broken during one of
the crash landings
and sergeant first class joe murray
america's only casualty
our night that night was our morale
and that's something again you you
covered these details in the book but
one of the one of the aircraft actually
crash-landed on purpose into the
compound right
blue boy yeah
and the reason for that was
the
people making the planning
and initially they thought we'd
drop in a c-130
but they didn't know
if the guards had orders to shoot the
pows
if there was a rescue
attempt or
exactly what so they they planned on
having control of the guards
within 60 seconds a minute they gave us
a minute to have complete control of the
guards inside the compound
and that meant taken out to the two
guard towers and the third one up by
blue boy
and then controlling the guards and
being in there
and uh that's what we did i mean they
they did a they did a
great job on their end
it's just that there was no pows in
there
and the gun and the gun you know people
say well why were there guards
and
you know we don't know if they were why
there were guards but they were still in
the
towers when
we
we i say we the
red
green or our blue boy took care of them
so
our job was outside
we were really
teams the red wine green leaf and blue
boy all had specific tasks to accomplish
and that's what we did we worked on our
task to get that done and if everybody
did their task like we had practiced and
rehearsed so many times
it would be a great success and it was a
success from the standpoint of
doing the job of eliminating the threat
and controlling the pow camp and the
guards
we just didn't anticipate the pows not
being there
and that was the
heartbreaking part of it
you say this to say we were disappointed
would be an understate understatement
some of us talked about how maybe we
should have gone into hanoi we were
thinking crazy thoughts like that that's
how confident we were when we got some
rest at udon for a couple hours we flew
a c-130
and we were briefed again in the
auditorium what to say and more
importantly what not to talk about we
packed our duffel bag secured our
equipment and had a few hours to relax
the c-141 that we boarded was
one that had been prepped for medevac
ready to bring pows home
now its mission was just to bring us to
eglin
all the after actions reports were
finalized exhaust
auxiliary field number three and we
spent two days before heading home to
north carolina on c123s
so that's it you do like a debrief you
fill out your paperwork explaining what
exactly you did
and then you wrap up your you know at
the training site where you spent all
this time preparing for the mission
and then you say this landing at pope
air force base north carolina a couple
days later was a very happy time it was
happy for the raiders and for all the
people awaiting us families friends and
the army support personnel there to
process us back to our normal world at
fort bragg
in fact for me personally
that is the most memorable moment
it was not the training or the day or of
the launch
or the landing at sante for me it was
the landing at pope air force base i
will never forget what i witnessed that
day
i was a single guy so a couple of my
buddies came to pick me up but standing
there on the flight line when i looked
around at the men unloading from the
airplane i saw their wives and
children's running out to meet them it
really hit me
the bull had warned us that we had a 50
50 chance of not coming home a 50 50
chance of this moment never happening
if there had been a security breach it
was unlikely that we could have been
rescued
these warriors had laid their lives on
the line to rescue fellow warriors
four days after the raid on wednesday
november 25th 1970 president nixon
honored the sante raiders by having
raider representatives in a televised
ceremony in the white house's east room
that had to be pretty mm-hmm that's
pretty cool pretty crazy
so it was on the news and everyone now
he almost immediately knew what had
happened right
and the only reason for that was the
fact that hanoi had come on
and said they had been bombed
and
what they had been
not bombed but they had flares dropped
out over the city
and
that was the diversion process
so the united states had to come on and
say no we didn't bomb them we did a pow
raid
and these were
aircraft that were dropping flares to
offset
the sante raiders coming in on the
backside
so it was kind of a political but you
know to justify what we had done
and uh the fact that the attempt was
made to free pows
which
was went a long way in that arena back
then
this is uh how how would you say this
level of uh
of
media attention compared to the bin
laden raid
i mean the thing about the bin laden
raid was
we weren't
the
the war wasn't inten as intense at that
point as vietnam was i mean vietnam was
right full-on
so it would have gotten a little bit
less attention i mean the the bin laden
raid was
yeah compared about as about as big of a
news story as there's ever been i think
yeah yeah that's true
and
you know uh the the good thing
if you look at the bin laden raid
compared to the sante ray
they were
they copied what the sante raid is about
and
that's the
good part about the sante raid is the
impact it's had
over the years
on all the raids that have been done
since then
have been modeled after the sante raid
because
not because of
the success it had of getting in and
getting out but the way the
the way they planned it
and all the information that went into
that
and how they
how they planned it
made an impact on the success of it yeah
i mean um i know i know you know admiral
mcraven he wrote
it was sort of like his uh thesis when
he was at the post-graduate school about
all the
most important special operations
missions in history right and he wrote
about desante raid
and then he was also like one of the
guys one of the
senior guys conducting the planning for
the bin laden rage so yeah there's a
direct
connection connection between the
lessons learned and
and the protocol that you use to to get
this done and
yeah no no doubt about that it's a
pretty interesting to see to see this
thread in history and yeah it is i mean
and today the sante raid is taught at
all the military schools and uh
you know socom in fact
uh they're making a movie on this it's
uh
and uh is socom making the movie or is
make in the movie it's a a
group of people that are doing a
documentary okay but the seventh special
forces is going to
uh
my understanding is they're going to
participate in having the sante raid as
a training film for
uh future because what they've done
they've interviewed a lot of the people
on the raid
and they've interviewed the pows and
they've kind of combined it all together
in fact next in may i'm going down
they're doing a screening on it
at socom
and i i'm going down to see the
screening and make sure
we we always told anybody that's going
to do this we want we want it to be
authentic we don't want hollywood
so
last year i went out to phoenix and did
a
group the group is building this
movie on it
and they actually built the compound
and they used they had one of us from
each group so red wine green leaf and
blue boy and then navigation
john cargus colonel gargas who was air
force
the navigator that took us in
and
they made all of the uh
they wanted to know how we cleared a
building
they wanted to know all that stuff and
that's how the bar you know throwing the
hand grenades in and all that stuff
and they did a really good they have
done a really good job on it
and
they're they're shopping i think to
netflix and everything right now but
they're very close to having it
completed but they've really done a nice
job of making it
uh authentic as to what actually took
place and how it happened
so it would be a good training film
definitely yeah that'll be awesome to
see
um
you say here
i remember being told to report to the
rep parade field in my dress greens
this is december 9th 1970 for an award
ceremony it was a nice sunny cool day
when secretary of defense melvin laird
personally presented the medals to the
members of the sante raid there i stood
spit shine jump boots jump wings expert
rifle badge and the seventh special
forces group risen ribbon
brigadier general henry emerson the
commander of special forces at fort
bragg thanked the raiders for their
carriage and dedication we had reflected
well on the green berets
and then you all were awarded it was i
think six distinguished service crosses
five air force crosses were awarded
there was a total of 85 silver stars
which included all of the raiders right
and the following comments
were made by secretary of defense
melvin laird
he said this
we are here to honor the brave the brave
and dedicated men we confer on them
today awards that express their
gratitude their country's gratitude and
admiration
the mission for which these men
volunteered called for undaunted courage
and deep compassion
they were asked to go deep into enemy
territory to search for and if possible
to rescue their comrades in arms who are
prisoners of war
they performed their mission flawlessly
from the outset the president the
nation's top military leadership and i
gave total and unqualified support to
this mission i knew as these men did how
grave were the risks they willingly
undertook
i knew
as these men did that there was a chance
of disappointment and even of failure
but the reasonable chance to return to
freedom americans held captive made this
mission well worth the risk if a similar
chance to save americans were to arise
tomorrow i would act
just as i did in approving and
supporting the effort at sante
man that's uh not too often the
secretary of defense shows up at your
command to start handing out 85 silver
stars
huge deal
um after that i'm going to the book here
you say they gave each of us 30 days of
leave uncharged against our balance we
got 30 days of free leave that's nice so
i went home for a whole month of
december back home in missouri we talked
about a little about the mission but not
too much it's funny how some people
don't understand the significance of a
combat raid i wasn't going to try and
impress it upon them most of my friends
had not gone to the military so i didn't
have any significant conversations with
them about the raid some had got married
and were busy with their own lives my
dad was a good listener for me he
expressed his pride and after a few
beers at the east side tavern on in
moberly he even told me some of his
friends
even told some of his friends what i had
done but to tell you the truth after
about four or five days i was ready to
head back to brag and my army buddies
then you got life lesson eight here
it says veterans we all have a mission
listen to your fellow veterans it is
important for the veteran but is also
important for the listener it is
important for america good stories and
bad they need to be told please take my
request to heart and talk with a veteran
and that's one thing that you have in
this book
um you've got a whole it's over 140
pages of this book is all the different
perspective we've just told your
perspective and it's very interesting to
hear your perspective as the youngest
guy on the raid
somebody with no combat experience
but you have the perspective of
a bunch of different people not just the
raiders but the support people the the
aircraft the pilots the crew you've got
incredible
amount of stories to be told that are
told in this book that every one of them
gives a different angle of the story
it's and how that came about when i
started writing my i started writing the
book in 2012 my daughter went to
afghanistan that time
and she was asking you know what would
you do and i thought
i'm on a document there's been several
books on the raid
but none by anybody that was on the
ground
so
that's kind of what prompted me to do it
but the
the
thing that i i got out of that was
in the process i realized that
i wanted more than my opinion so i we
have an email chain that we go out on
so i sent an email out to all the pows
and the raiders and the support guys
if you have
something that you would like to put in
the book you know
send it to me i'll put it in unedited
into the book
and i got about 40 of them
and some are one paragraph some are
three or four or five pages you know but
it's their memorable moment
on the raid or about the rate or
whatever it might be and it you know it
just gives a whole different perspective
you know from a pow standpoint to a guy
flying a you know
mid-cap over us and
it it really i think rounded out the
book yeah it's uh i'm not gonna read it
today get the book but the story about
uh the guys got hit with a frag from the
surface-to-air missile and ended up
punching out just hearing that story
with him talking about you know they're
they're just having a conversation yeah
like we're about to we're about to eject
from an aircraft which by the way is
a life and death thing this is
when you eject from an aircraft there's
i don't know what the chance is that
you're gonna die but there's definitely
a strong chance that you're you're
you know ejecting through the canopy
going 400 miles an hour or whatever it
is that was ted lowry yeah yeah there's
a decent chance you're going to die just
from that and then you're going to land
and wherever vietnam laos the ocean you
know what the hell is going to happen
and these guys are talking about it like
hey i think i think we're going to have
to punch out yeah okay well let me know
when you're ready they're doing it like
this yeah i'm freaking calm cool and
collected
lowry's enrolling on the great guy too
didn't
get to meet him
and then and then of course they end up
having to get picked up you know the
next day yeah the next day they spend
the night it's like a little
afterthought of the book but it's it's
its own story in itself so
you're uh taking your own advice on life
less nate and getting these other
stories out there um
so check that out check out to get the
book for that stuff as well you say here
life goes on the next week i was back at
d company seventh special forces group
at fort bragg that's it
back to back to normal life right you
end up uh
you end up
getting involved in the sport of
orienteering which is like map and
compass right while you're running
basically the next year uh you you spend
time doing this orienteering sort of
like as the as part of the team of
seventh special forces group
[Music]
you say by december of 1971 our team had
represented special forces in several
orienteering meets i finished 15th in
the u.s military championship seventh in
the u.s championship 45th in the
canadian championship
so you go through that and then
uh you say when i heard in december 1971
that the army was offering early outs
that really appealed to me i felt ready
to do my own thing
and not to be told what to do all the
time i took advantage of the opportunity
separating january 5th 1972.
started back at junior college january
7th back home
so how long was your total service
well i was active three years
and i was in reserve for four i stayed
in okay so were you uh
were you actually doing reserve duty on
the weekends and whatnot
i was
making money to go to college
so you go to school
uh what'd you study in school uh
business
bachelor of art in independent study of
and then you graduate and you're not you
know it's 1974.
you're not having a little bit of
trouble finding a job but oh yeah
[Music]
but uh
at one of the sante raiders uh reunions
you you
get connected with ross perot yes
he uh he had a reunion in
1974 i guess
with all the pows and the raiders at san
francisco
and
[Music]
we had an afternoon he brought all the
raiders and the pows together and he
said you know if there's anything i can
ever do for any of you let me know
and
as a result of that i thought you know
i'm out of college i don't have a job i
need help you know so i wrote a letter
to ross fero and
i got a response back that they flew me
down for an interview and
i was hired to work for eds and
so he kept his word
that's pretty amazing and then how long
did you do how long to work for your eds
i worked for eds for about three years
and then you end up with another job
and what was the next job you got i i
went
from there to selling computer furniture
and
worked for a company called wrightline i
worked for them for about five years
and then
i was hired away from that company by
greg kalis who was my old boss at that
time there
and selling
united micrographics and
he sold the business and i decided to
start my own so
i went into my own business of document
imaging and document imaging
where we scanned documents and storm
digitize them and is that still running
today yes what's it called delta systems
delta systems
nothing to do with delta force it just
happens to be the name of the company
and we're in kansas city and
we uh and you were doing that in the
late 80s you were doing that mm-hmm
19. you went a jump starter because
that's everything's digital now i know
and it's amazing how much is still being
printed though today yeah it's crazy
and that's still running right now delta
systems
how big is the company
uh well there's only about five of us
so we're a small company but we
we do a lot of work
we're in probably know maybe 15 20 30
states
and
we have resellers that sell our product
then we do a lot of health
medical
but you name an industry we probably
have a system installed in it so
um
whether it's government or
we just
you're out there anybody's got paper i'm
gonna get rid of it we can help
and you you know you mentioned earlier
your wife
marsha
um
when did you meet her
i meant
what was that what was the arc the story
arc there
we were
at the time i was a member of the data
processing management association in
kansas city
and we were
i was on the board of directors for that
and
we were
down at a bar after a board meeting one
night and
marcia and her girlfriend walked in the
place was packed and a couple of the
guys that were on the board happened to
get up and leave just as they walked in
so we had two open seats
and we said come sit down here with us
and they did and
so i met marcia that was in september of
let's see that would have been 18
84 84.
yeah
and
so
we ended up getting married and had a
she had a little boy aaron
who is down in texas and my daughter
would you met here hannah
and uh
so we're
we
got married in
october
20th of 1984
and
i started the business in 1989.
so
it was uh
and what was the deal was there some
story about scuba diving in here did you
guys get married underwater or something
or engaged underwater what was the story
we got engaged i had a we were in hawaii
in a place called witches brew which is
around hanama bay
on the
island of oahu and
i have a friend over there that was a
dental hygienist and she had some that
red dental floss
so i wrapped the ring and that tied it
on it put it in a little remember when
it had the 35 millimeter camera cases
yeah put that down in my website
we swam out to the place called witch's
brew and we went down about 30 feet
under
and i stopped her and i said i pulled
out mine i dangled it and
of course everything's three times
bigger over water
she thought
it melted when we got on the surface
she went from 1.5 carats to 0.5
exactly stuff
but uh and then you had uh so you had a
son
aaron and then your daughter
she ended up joining the army yes she
was uh so you got third generation army
that's true
and she actually shipped off to
afghanistan at one point correct right
she was a chemical officer
and uh how hard was that for you that
was tough
i know it was tough on her it's tough on
me you know i just
you know it's it's one thing you know
when you when you go but it's when your
daughter goes
you got a lot of other thoughts going
through the mind and
she's a very strong woman
she was
went to college at warrensburg and she
was the
first rotc
a female com battalion commander
she was the first female to go to jump
school
from there
and the first one to go to afghanistan
so
and now she's a deputy sheriff over
johnson county kansas and
she's
loves her job must be the daughter of
ahsante raider yeah
got it honestly i guess you know
for sure mother always worried about her
but i tried not to show my concerns
but
it was when your daughter's in harm's
way you you got to be a little
uh crazy like i worry when my daughter's
one of my daughters goes to the grocery
store i can't even imagine you're going
to afghanistan so god bless you
and um you know that's the the last life
lesson that you have in the book
um
you you say life lesson nine sacrificial
living
that scene as we arrived at pope air
force base back in november 1970 really
made an impression on me
it's not only the soldiers but also
their wives who are heroes these
families are the type of people our
world needs
people who know this life is not just
about their own convenience
i am thankful for what these families
and also
those of first responders and civilian
life do for our country and for freedom
around the world
and that's your
uh that's sort of your your final life
lesson there
and like i said the stories in the book
and we only covered a fraction of the
book today but it's packed full of more
information the
just it's
very powerful um
and
there's one one thing i wanted to cover
which we haven't really touched on yet
which is the impact of the raid
right because clearly go on this
operation the operation is to rescue uh
pows and as we've covered there was no
pows there and it'd be easy to think
well then that must be a failed mission
but
that couldn't be further from the truth
the there was a huge impact for
the pows and and part of the section of
the book where you have other people's
stories you have a bunch of commentary
from
some of the people that were pows in
vietnam and we've had some of these
heroes on this podcast incredible human
beings
uh you have some i'm going to just read
some of these highlights u.s air force
first lieutenant j.h spike nazmuth p.o.w
from 1966 to 1973. he says i was in
hanoi six and a half years
after the raid the guards were clearly
shaken by what they heard they were
digging holes like mad it was a real
show to watch at dawn the nva were still
running around
you've heard of a chinese fire drill
they're digging foxholes right outside
our cell they've got machine guns set up
all over the prison yard they're digging
in foxholes real deep i can't believe
all the freaking foxholes first time i'd
seen the little bastards work up a sweat
uh u.s air force first lieutenant joe
crecka p.o.w 1966 to 1973 on the night
of november 21st 1970 i was at p.o.w and
camp faith a camp just about 10 miles
south of sante and about the same
distance west
of hanoi as sante
it didn't come out until a few days
later what had happened within 48 hours
we were all packed up placed onto six by
six trucks and ferried into hanoi
so this is an impact direct impact of
the raid they started consolidating
these prisoners which is a massive
morale boost he says whereas before we
had been held in much smaller groups one
two three four
or even eight or ten there were now 50
of us all together in a room of about 35
feet by 70 feet new faces new stories to
tell and hear and putting faces of
fellow americans we only knew by maine
by name language classes were taught in
german because they they organized like
a educational system once they were
together they had a
just uh they started being more
productive
language classes were taught german
spanish and even russian math classes
were divided into three levels
appropriately x y and z
we also had courses in history sociology
politics religion wine selection yes we
had a wine tasting class meat cutting
and lumber selection
and i thought of a course in physics
automotive theory and practice as well
as one on classical music themes and
composers
he said we were still being held captive
but since the raid on sante prison camp
by the incomparable sante raiders life
was so much better hats off to all the
raiders and those who supported the raid
air force navy marines and all those at
their support bases on land at sea bravo
another one captain a u.s air force
captain leon lee ellis
sante pow camp from 1967 to 1973. the
night of november 20th and 21st at camp
faith we pows were awakened in the
middle of night hearing explosions
aircraft sam's launching and several
minutes of chaos we could not have
guessed that our old camp at sante just
a few miles up the road was entertaining
guests uninvited guests for sure the
next morning we saw fear in the eyes of
the guards and turnkeys and within 48
hours we were loaded up and moved back
to hanoi for the first time ever we were
in large groups
but we were not rescued by the raid in
many ways our sanity and teamwork were
saved by that event we will always be
indebted to the raiders for what they
did for us
u.s navy lieutenant junior grade porter
halliburton pow
1965-1973 at camp faith on november 21st
we heard gunfire and jet noise from
somewhere close by but had no idea what
was happening the elation we felt
knowing that our government had tried to
rescue us was the most powerful morale
booster imaginable we were especially
thankful to the guys of the sante
raiders who had volunteered for this
mission and risked their lives to try
and rescue us
another one u.s navy commander paul
gallante
sante p.o.w camp
he said the sante raid itself was the
most memorable moment of my captivity we
knew uncle sam wouldn't forget about us
the sante raid proved that
u.s air force first lieutenant mike
burns pow 1968-1973
we were all jubilant because after so
many years of waiting something finally
happened fighter pilots like to make
things happen and are probably the worst
probably worse than most people at doing
nothing
u.s air force major dw wayne waddell
p.o.w 1967-1973
you guys made the biggest positive
change in our sojourn in north vietnam
and we can never repay you for taking
that risk thanks
and i'll read one more this is u.s air
force
first lieutenant larry lucky
chesley
camp
1966 to 1973 i was captured in 1966 and
spent the next
2495 days just short of seven years as a
pow
i was at sante we had prayed for months
that god would move us to a better camp
he did on july 14th i guess a person
needs to be careful what he prays for he
might get it we loaded in the trucks and
went to a better camp which fulfilled
our prayers then the raid came we were
blessed once more when we were moved to
a better camp in hanoi where we had big
rooms about 48 of us in a room we could
now teach each other things such as
languages choir movie we told movies and
we had programs on each sunday and also
for christmas easter 4th of july marine
day etc
when we got packages and that was not
very often those who got packages shared
them with those that received nothing i
never received any packages or letters
for four years yes for four years my
wife and family did not know if i was
alive or dead i am eternally grateful
to the heroic things that the men of the
sante raid did for our country
and those incarcerated in vietnam
now that came the fourth airline allied
command
their motto was return with honor
yeah it's outstanding
yeah and and as i said i was just
hitting the highlights i didn't even
cover all these pows the the impact that
you all had
conducting this operation which by the
way i haven't mentioned the the
operation name was ivory coast right
that was the name of the operation
um
but
you know the the impact that you all had
was just incredible
and
amazing to be able to sit here and and
talk to you some someone from a raid
that i've studied and read about for
many many years
uh and and just an incredible
opportunity to be able to sit here and
talk to you and and hear these stories
from you um for everybody out there
uh
the book is just an incredible piece of
history and it it's it's available on
kindle if you're one of these digital
people there's an audiobook
um traditional print
you know whether you want softcover
hardcover but
just an incredible book go out and get
it we just covered a fraction of the
stories today um
it's an amazing amazing piece of history
thank you
um probably a good place to to wrap it
up echo charles do you have any
questions i got nothing outstanding okay
thank you wow that's
that's a rare occasion i was going to
ask about the wine tasting but that
wasn't your thing right no we'd have to
ask uh captain charlie plumber yeah
maybe
will reader bill reader about that one
do we know what we learn in a wine
tasting class
do any of us know that
probably different ways that wine are
made to taste different ways and
no i think it goes deeper when you talk
to the pows and we've talked to pows the
deals come next time because i don't
know
the amount of focus that they have on
food oh yeah is incredible they go
through everything that they've ever
eaten in their whole lives literally
they have they'll talk about menu
they'll prepare a a christmas eve dinner
menu for months right and just think
about what they're going to eat
i mean because those guys were getting
fed uh you know these little little
balls of rice with
chips of wood in it yeah they'd be happy
if there was a bug in there because
they'd get a little extra protein
um
yeah that's
amazing i know i do to have those guys
back on the podcast will be it'll be
awesome to be able to ask them you know
what they remember about about this and
how it impacted them but
amazing story terry you got any final
thoughts you want to share
no i
you know it was a team effort from the
guys that's supporting us
i mean when you think about how many
people were involved in the sante raid
56 guys were on the ground but we had
i would say 5600 helping us
guys that were on the ships you know we
had
the air
their aircraft came from
uh three different uh
air air probing
[Music]
carriers
and i think it was six or seven
bases
and
it was a joint effort i mean there were
so many people involved in it but what's
interesting is
nobody knew what was going on
they were all compartmentalized they
were all compartmentalized
colonel
sidner or colonel
simons
and
general manor
had a letter from the joint chiefs of
staff
that said if these guys need anything
give it to them no questions asked and
that's what they hand carried to every
base they went to
and there was no questions they never
was turned down on anything they
requested
and
you know so
that's how high in the echelon it went
but also how many people
lower in the echelon had an impact
and helped with the sante raid
and some of them probably didn't even
know they were doing it because of the
secrecy well you barely knew you were
doing it until a few hours before
yeah that's the part you know
an hour before we took off is when we
knew where we were going
so
well but security was for our own
benefit absolutely so you know i've
never questioned why they kept it a
secret
i was just glad they did you know so
well i'm glad we can hear about the
secret now and uh thank you for joining
us out here pleasure it's been a real
honor to be you know to all the veterans
out there thank you
for your service to this great country
i know we got some roughy roads out
there but we also
have been through them before and we'll
we'll survive we just have to
pick up our bootstraps and chug on
well you you all um
have given us lessons learned and and
thank you for your for your service and
for your contribution to america and for
your contribution to
special forces and really to special
operations as a whole
uh as i said
you and your your brothers in arms that
conducted this this operation
you made a huge impact
not only like i said to the pows but
you made a huge impact to the morale of
the country and you made a huge impact
to
special operations and our trajectory in
history
so
thank you for coming on and thank you
for everything that you and your fellow
sante raiders have done
we will not forget you thank you sir
thank you
and with that
terry buckler has left the building
pretty awesome to be able to sit down
and talk to him echo yeah how do you
feel about
it's interesting how do you feel about
that whole
scenario
not knowing where you're going to
execute
this massive mission and you don't know
where you're going until an hour before
you go yeah
yeah obviously kind of
there's a lot to think about it
to start with where it's one of those
things where it's almost like you're my
i would imagine anyway that your mind
just kind of goes to okay um
i'm here to essentially do a mission and
so it kind of blocks that of course you
can be wondering i would imagine i don't
know but of course you're imagining what
you're going to do but either way it's
like it forces your mind to just be
prepared for kind of anything
but it's still very off-putting
to know this is what i thought about
even more so though than that
is
so you know
how he started the his business
afterwards
right and it's like oh digitizing like
documents it's like oh bro you didn't
start like some tactical shooting course
just uh you know something like but it
just goes to show where like
even tilt wasn't he like a reporter
afterwards
for a full career by the way yeah
so it just goes to show like how
a military man
kind of like a jiu jitsu man
is like
right you don't know like he he can be
anybody yeah and he can go and perform
and do these crazy things hold the
guinness book of world records for quick
kill and yeah whatever you said there
and then go to his quote-unquote normal
life and just start printing or
digitizing printed documents just like
in jiu jitsu you're like man this guy
he's kicking my ass he must be some sort
of a
like i don't know construction guy or
maybe like some some real hard job and
he's like oh no he's an accountant
okay all right and it it just paints
that picture more yeah you know and
there's something to be said for that's
the way veterans have done it for a long
time i mean the world war ii veterans
came home
and they
went and got jobs doing things you know
they went back to school they did the gi
bill
like
you you don't have to you know not
everyone's going to come home and start
a tactical shooting company you know
like that's not
that's not the normal thing what makes
it seem normal is you know when someone
owns a tactical shooting company that
they were a veteran so you're like oh
well everyone that's a veteran must
start a tactical shooting company that's
not necessarily true
so it feels that's the yeah it feels
it feels that way because
there's no one that went to college and
studied
uh you know
studied economics and then started a
tactical shooting company right that's
true so you don't you don't have that
data in your head yeah so you think well
oh this guy's got a tactical shooting
company he was a veteran another guy has
a tactical shooting company and he's a
veteran another guy so all veterans must
start tactical shooting companies no a
lot of veterans go and
start
well data processing companies and
i work with i mean i work with a lot of
companies where i work with veterans all
the time that
you know we're talking about their
business we're talking about what they
do and then occasionally oh yeah well i
was in the army or oh i was in the
marine corps and they have a totally
separate job and they have a different
career and that's
very normal
it's not abnormal
it's actually more normal it's more
normal to do that than it is to start a
tactical shooting company
yeah and even and there's more to
i don't mean to put too fine of a point
on it but of course tactical shooting
okay but like any kind of adventurous
and this is
just my experience like the bias that
came from my experience with meeting all
these guys where you can micah think
doing all the all these
adventurous things yeah you know where
it's like you go through these crazy
missions or all these crazy military
experiences you come home and boom let's
switch missions into some other quote
unquote adventurous
scenario you know and a lot of people a
lot of us or not us but a lot of people
do that yeah we see that you know i
think it's your awareness bias yeah
because when you become aware of
something that sounds like that you've
got what's that person's background oh
they were a veteran that makes sense
yeah you don't look at an accountant and
say whoa i wonder what military branch
they were when they probably were there
there's a decent chance that they were
in the military there's all kinds of
veterans out there working i mean i meet
veterans all the time when i go and work
with companies companies just so you
know
companies have
veteran programs inside their company so
i'll work with a financial company and
inside their financial company they have
like a veterans group and they'll say
hey can we spend 15 minutes doing q a
with you
and i go oh with who and they go oh we
have a veterans group we have you know
of our 2000 employees we have
274 veterans and we
we we sell
insurance or we
manufacture widgets or whatever but they
have a bunch of veterans that work there
and that's every i mean when i work with
big tech companies they have veterans
when i work with financial companies
they have construction companies
everyone's got veterans
it's just that it stands out in your
head when someone owns a shooting
company because you think it's cool
so it's normal for a veteran to come
home and do what they're going to do
that's that's that's the way the world
works but and this is a good example the
interesting thing about his career was
just
it's it's almost like this guy was in
the nfl for
one season
and he didn't play any games except the
super bowl
right
like that's the kind of incredible and
then he and then that was it he retired
after the super bowl one game
and went out there won the championship
and
and then carried on with the rest of his
life did three years yeah
three years
like and doing that
such a such a high profile mission
probably one of the most well the most
high profile mission for special
operations at that time
it's amazing that is it's crazy so
uh good stuff awesome to be able to talk
with him and this is a hugely
influential mission for special
operations uh we appreciate you
supporting us by the way out there
if you want to support us and you want
to support yourself
get go to jockofield.com get some of
these beverages by the way
freaking i did not get a lot of sleep
last night got i got stuck in my
in my roller coaster of brain thought
yeah which is which is not i i can't
stand it yeah you know
i can't stand it and i the here's what
was a bummer was i i had bad sleep the
night before and i was like oh i had a
good workouts and i thought i'm going to
be asleep like a baby and i'm going to
bed early
like you know 9 30 i'm getting ready to
go to sleep i'm thinking oh this is
going to be great i'm going to feel
great i went to bed about you know 10 10
i'm
laying in bed in the darkness
and i've got the eyes are shifting back
and forth you know counting the walls
and thinking about this and thinking
about that and thinking about this and
thinking about that and thinking about
this so that happened until one o'clock
in the morning wait so when that happens
then okay so this because that happens
that's a real thing where but is it the
kind where you're thinking about one or
two things over and over and over and
over again describe this
this is the way it feels have you ever
been to
uh
uh disney land no okay there's a ride
there it's called space mountain
and in space mountain you're on a roller
coaster but you can't see very much in
front of you it's in the dark basically
so you're suddenly you're going in one
direction then you go in a different
direction you go in a different
direction
so that's what my mind is like i'm on
i'm on a roller coaster and it's dark
but i just keep seeing like a new idea
comes up then another new idea then
another new idea then another new idea
and it just doesn't stop
and maybe sometimes it does circle back
to the original idea which just starts
the whole process again
but
i am
getting i probably slept two and a half
hours last night which which sucks i
wanted to sleep more but
here i am
here i am so and i drank this i normally
don't have two goes in one podcast but i
did
so
you may need some clean energy in your
life
you don't need to have necessarily some
jittery energy you don't need to have
you don't need to have sugar intake you
don't need to give yourself type 2
diabetes no you can just get yourself a
go yeah get yourself a go jockofuel.com
get yourself some milk i'm going to go
home and have milk by the way because i
haven't eaten yet because i fasted yeah
so
we're feeling that yeah and especially i
said this before it's but if if you're
lifting weights or
which i did lift this morning by the way
bad workout not a great workout like i
mean
i was borderline hey
am i gonna get the benefit from this
workout right now yeah the answer was
finally yes so how many days of like
shitty sleep do you have to go through
to actually get a bad word because you
can go one day junk sleep and still get
a sick workout yeah i i don't know i
don't know but i will get good sleep
tonight that's that's the nice thing but
for me two days if i go the second day
bad sleep sorry workouts you work out
you might as well not even do it yeah
jump jump up it depends on
what i kind of
if i if i
go into it and
get kind of like a little bit of anger
going yeah then i'm pissed then i might
get jacked some more still but i just
did a weak workout but do you are any of
your work because it's different kind of
workouts but are any of your workouts um
like based on
i for like a better term like a
bodybuilding scenario okay so yeah put
it this way then and tell me if this
applies to you your workouts are you so
if i do
i don't know
chest
monday where are we at and then i don't
feel the pump and i'm tired that is like
there's something wrong with me
physically whether i didn't get enough
sleep i didn't eat enough and not
hydrate or whatever but if you don't get
the pump that's a big indicator and then
there's other stuff where it's like you
just feel weak and just not into it
mentally all this other factors but do
you have any workout where it's like
you're you feel the physical like pump
versus if you don't
i'd say i kind of feel that on a lot of
workouts
yeah you know yeah like dips you feel
dips to feel good but muscle ups too
like when you get done with muscle ups
you feel like kind of jacked all the way
around oh sure uh
yeah so you know what when jason gardner
said the other day that he takes one
discipline go pill in the morning that's
i haven't tried it yet but that seems
like a good move yeah just to get a
little
a little kicker yeah yeah i haven't
tried it yet i i have them before i'm
like going to speak and i don't want to
have a bladder filled with liquid yeah
distracting you but you can feel those
things
feel those things for real um so there
you go you want some milk you want some
joint warfare you want some krill oil go
to jockofield.com you get that you can
get the drinks at wawa by the way we're
moving to some other convenience stores
right now
also some other
some other big uh news coming on the
front yeah for jocko fuel vitamin shop
you can get it there as well so check
that out jacofuel.com
what else also origin usa yeah
american manufactured goods durable
goods as it were i didn't know what that
meant by the way durable goods
yes like clothes work clothes pants
shoes that kind of stuff
um the new hunting line thing yeah when
is that going down because look do i
hunt you know it's debatable
probably not i don't think it's
debatable yeah well i do not
either way
uh like
it can be used for other stuff i will
have a hunting line
this summer
late summer to be prepared for the
hunting season
in september that's hunting so well
there's there's other hunts but the the
hunting season we're aiming for is that
september hunting season so yeah we're
coming is there different hunting
seasons for different places different
places different animals different
weapons
okay all right so there's a whole bunch
of things and it can go you know in
yes different different animals
different weapons different seasons you
got a bunch of stuff to contend with and
we'll be making stuff for all of it a
very very cool venture working with some
great people
working with cam haynes which is awesome
i mean he's just a machine so it's it's
that guy is possessed and obsessed with
hunting and so it's great to have him
giving guidance on
making the gear exactly
as it should be made yeah no compromise
hey it has to be able to perform if
you're going to keep up with cam haynes
in the woods like that clothing has to
keep up with campaigns that clothing is
thinking to itself all right i'm gonna
be put through the ringer yeah so that's
what we're talking about we have the
highest possible standard
yeah and like as it applies to actual
hunting because let's face it when i'm
looking at that thing i'm i'm pretty
much only concerned
about how it's going to look on me
or when i'm doing what everyone be doing
with it but
um yeah that make that makes sense yeah
campaigns i recently connected with them
online too so there you go got a new
friend dude yeah hell yeah hell yeah
boys so originusa.com if you want to
check some of that stuff out yeah also
jiu-jitsu stuff oh yeah by the way of
course
oh jesus stuff all made in america which
is a big deal
that's a huge deal maine and north
carolina we're we're making it it's
unbelievable
bringing it back
also there you go jacqueline has a store
jackostore.com that's where you can get
your discipline equals freedom shirts
and hats and merch it's good stuff this
quality it's not just it's not just like
my daughter always says that stuff
you know it's weird how kids nowadays
well
let's face it my kids and their friends
i'm sure it's you know most kids were
their terminology is like you know merch
is like obviously we know what that
means it's short for merchandise which
is merchandise is a specific thing so we
know the translation they don't even
know they're just like murdered
that's the official word you know my
daughters speak in a kind of their own
language with and i went and saw one of
my daughters up at my middle daughter up
at college and got to listen to her and
her friends and they have
their own words their own language
and it's pretty funny to listen to oh
yeah suss
suspect yeah which is suspicious like
right so we know that we know sus like
oh that looked kind of sus so i'd be
like okay obviously she that girl meant
well
like oh that's a suspect situation but
either one of those things could be sus
but suspect is a slang term derived from
suspicious right because suspect as a
word is a person no but you could also
say oh that that chair is suspect
whether it's going to you wouldn't say
suspicious you say that thing is suspect
no you'd say suspicious you can't say
there's a noun you could say that i'm
pretty sure suspect isn't now
well i guess we'll have to go to it's
not at the
i know you're an english major but we
might want to revisit that here's my uh
hypothesis
suspicious is the adjective suspect is
the noun sus is like
could go both ways
amalgam of the whole deal all right your
whole english literature understanding
is sus at this time
either way jockostar.com is where you
can get all
this merch yeah but it's more than just
merch it's like good it's quality it's
like it's stuff you're supposed to
actually wear and it's it's also uh you
know part you know it's part of the game
it's part of like you know
if you're in the game it's part of the
culture yeah it's part of the game part
of being in the game
i remember when we first kind of had the
podcast i would say like oh how did you
get into the game
i would still say that me people i
haven't said in a while maybe i need to
bring it back
how did you get in the game and then i
heard you on rogan you know i heard you
on tim ferriss or whatever yeah you know
how did you get in the game
my uncle told me or whatever it's real
so there you go if you want to get in
the game
dot com and represent it's true
also subscribe
if you haven't already leave a review
and you can subscribe to a bunch not a
bunch but other podcasts as well that
we're doing if we don't know
which ones we're unraveling with daryl
cooper we're getting kind of crazy
sometimes on those yeah can you
get kind of crazy with dc that's how you
gotta roll dc he's got a long trajectory
of thought
i understand by the way i try and
explain that to people yeah dc's got a
long trajectory of thought he's he's
gonna make his case over
extended period of time so if you if you
hear him say something and when i say
say something when you hear daryl cooper
say something for three hours yeah he's
only representing that's like the
warm-up for him
great you gotta keep listening so keep
listening to that uh and then you'll see
that there's probably a more balanced
overall picture but sometimes he seems a
little bit
you know you got to take got to get
listened to dc you got to listen to the
man so check out check out that one
jocko unraveling uh grounded podcast
warrior kid podcast we got the jocko
underground appreciate your support
there jockowinderground.com if you want
to support freedom of speech
you gotta you gotta kind of pay
attention that right now we know we got
elon musk
he just bought a chunk of twitter
hopefully that's a positive sign in the
world yeah maybe he bought it to maybe
influence more freedom of speech
i mean that's the concept right
because
that's what kind of he's about
that and putting rockets into space and
making electric electrical cars is true
made in america
so there you go that's uh jock
underground.com if you wanna help us out
there check out the youtube channel
check out psychological warfare check
out flipside canvas dakota meyer dakota
meyer we gotta get he just went to
ukraine by the way yeah whatever his
dakota meyer he's a medal of honor
recipient i was talking to him yesterday
he's like i just got back i'm like oh
how was ukraine he was in keeve right
dude i mean
just getting after it so
if you want to help uh support dakota
meyer and all of his madness go to
flipsidecampus.com buy some something
cool to hang on your wall yeah that's
what you should do in my opinion got a
bunch of books check out the books who
will go into sante
p.o.w.camp that's what we covered today
we covered a fraction of it today terry
butler check that out i written a bunch
of books too if you want to get some
more
of the conceptual
ideas that i speak of you can check out
any of the books that i wrote you can
check out we have a leadership
consultancy called echelon
frontechnomfront.com
if you want to come
check some of that out
we have we have an online academy
for human beings that have to interact
with other human beings
go to
extremeownership.com you can got a
question for me come and ask me you can
ask me on a zoom call i'm there you can
just ask me your question about your
boss about your employee about your
girlfriend about your boyfriend about
your kid about your jujitsu tournament
whatever you want to ask me
we want to hear your questions go to
extremeownership.com
take we got a bunch of courses to take
about how to utilize the dichotomy of
leadership
about how to utilize cover and move
lots of important things
extremeownership.com if you want to help
service members
active and retired you want to help out
their families gold star families check
out mark lee's mom mama lee she's got a
charity organization it's a wonderful
thing that helps out in incredible ways
if you want to donate or you want to get
involved go to america's
mightywarriors.org you can also check
out
heroes and
horses.com micah fink
who i think you mentioned a few minutes
ago
yeah cause you're like what is micah
fink gonna do when he gets done with his
time in the seal teams he's probably
gonna do something badass yes sir so
heroes and horses.com check that out as
far as ekko and i go we're both on
we're on twitter or on the gram or
on facebook where we're possibly
going to pull you into the algorithm but
we don't want you to get pulled into the
algorithm we want you to cut away from
the algorithm
echoes that equal charles i am at jocko
willink
you can also check out
terry buckler he's got a facebook page
if you want to check out his facebook
page see what he's up to
uh facebook at terry buckler and
thank you once again to terry buckler
for coming on
for sharing his experiences and thanks
to terry and the rest of the
sante raiders
the mighty special forces green brays
and the other support personnel the
pilots the air crew that took the risks
to attempt to rescue our fellow
servicemen
and thanks all the military personnel
out there right now who are willing to
take risk to protect and secure freedom
around the world and thanks
for the work
done by our police and law enforcement
firefighters paramedics emts dispatchers
correctional officers border patrol
secret service and all first responders
who sacrifice
to protect and secure us and our way of
life here at home
and to everyone else out there remember
some of the key lessons from terry
buckler today
add humor to your life
especially in tough situations be
excellent in everything you do always
train and improve
be patient but know when to be
aggressive don't be a complainer don't
be indispensable be thankful for those
who sacrifice for our freedom
and
be prepared for death
make sure the day that you meet your
maker isn't the first time you've been
introduced
because if you're prepared for death you
are free to live life fearlessly
and that
is a good plan
so go out there
and get after it
and until next time this is echo and
jocko
out